gonna need to send in the glow worm feds
and or Army groom of creeps cause we
ain't going nowhere
[Music]
[Applause]
remember none of this is possible
without you join the fight and sign up
for mug club today at louder with
crowder.com mug Club gain access to an
unrivaled catalog of unapologetic and
entertaining creators including the
Hodge twins Nick depalo Brian Callan and
of course Alex Jones all that and
everything you see today is entirely
funded by viewers like you for 89
annually join the fight at Lotto with
credit.com Mud Club today
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
it's okay it's gonna be better than that
tonight it's the debate stream it's
going on right now now most of you don't
care because Donald Trump isn't there
but we'll talk about that too uh you can
use a promo code right now Crowder GOP
debate you get ten dollars off right at
mukclub ladder with credit.com or use
the hashtag Crowder GOP debate remember
people used to say hashtag not anymore
right yeah but we don't see any more
pound sign I don't necessarily know what
people use but we'll be live streaming
this debate here from Rumble we actually
have a seat a booth right down there in
Milwaukee where Gerald was which of
course means Indian burial ground
Milwaukee native tongue nice uh and any
candidates who you know have the stones
to sit down we'll have I think we have
Vivek uh confirmed looks like uh I think
Darren's just gonna grab him and then
walk him over his feet won't even touch
the ground okay fellow well great so if
you by the way we have the YouTube we
have the YouTube dump button so if you
see this at any point tonight
that means head on over to rumble
because we're live streaming on Rumble
which is where you should be anyway you
just click that button below and you get
to join up at my club so question to you
right off the bat what do you expect who
do you think will be a front runner
we're going to give you some predictions
here tonight uh kind of go through what
we think are the need to knows and uh by
that I mean none of it is really
necessary
none of it's a need to know and I don't
know why you would want to know it but
it pays to be informed uh we have G
Morgan Jr here with me how are you sir
I'm doing well fresh off a flight from
Milwaukee to get back here it's a
horrible town I mean I don't I don't say
I don't say it from an elitist point of
view as far as it being flyover it's
just a very bad place it has bad beer
lists in a lot of places yeah they go to
four different spots to get a good beer
Milwaukee or Grain Belt no it all sucks
it was all that kind of stuff and I was
like I just thought this was Midwestern
beer town you know like Iron City Lights
what do you uh no I just can I get a
triple or a quad somewhere say I don't
know hit that oh I should mention that
before first off of course you have here
today I guess not third chair it's like
a joint chair like he's like it's like a
Siamese twin growing out of my shoulder
a gargoyle really uh Nick I can I can't
imagine I'm excited I've almost seen it
uh Nick depalo who by the way you have
his date right there you can go to uh
yeah September 15th September 15th at
Rob's comedy Playhouse there's a name
nickdip.com is live on Mud Club Monday
through Thursday 5 p.m and you're
recovering from the vid yes I'm getting
over the vid luckily I scored some uh
was it wouldn't say that honors a point
guard
yeah I scored some
Ivermectin and some epoxy chlorofloam
did you use it on yourself you got it
from an Asian kid in front of the subway
back there um
already so I want to thank whoever got
that for me yeah we have no idea they
wouldn't be in the studio so hey before
we go on to we'll be giving our
predictions uh we were down there yeah
in Milwaukee and you actually will you
set this up for people we actually got
an interview or semi interview with
Vivek all right yeah we did so uh Vivek
actually had a bus set up he had a
really really cool setup uh right there
out in right in front of oh one thing
sorry really quickly first off Tim can
you put that down the lower third there
just whatever the the stream so people
know that we'll bring it up and watch
them there will be a pre-taped interview
that Tucker Carlson is uploading to his
Twitter's to his ex with Donald Trump
right I think they're airing it as a
live stream but we know it's pre-taped
and we will be covering that as well
with the Highlight so you can get it all
here in this one place sorry Gerald to
cut you no no you're fine he actually
had a really cool setup with his bus uh
and his team set up like this exclusive
event for everybody he was the one
person who did something cool at this
event all the other candidates just kind
of were getting into town kind of there
and so we had one of our guys go into
this they had the the access past
courtesy of Rumble hey we didn't give
that back sorry about that guys but did
you say did you say Vivek was cool his
his setup was like he's an Indian Fonzie
he had a lot of really like it was a
very nice setup like it was it was I
would go to and be like oh this is cool
they had a beer garden there maybe
that's why all the other places had
crappy beer all the music was at that
place but we asked him some questions
because you know you guys want to know
what these guys actually think about
some of the stuff that Alex Jones was
working on with covet elections and uh
we got up close and personal with him
and he had some good answers okay all
right well let's go well by the way but
I guess before that we should let you
know the drinking game rules as we have
for every single live debate stream uh
bring them up drinking game rules boom
anytime and you'll hear this ding
anytime president Trump has mentioned
you drink anytime 2020 January 6th is
mentioned dang you drink anytime a
moderator cuts off or interrupts a
candidate you drink any Thug Life moment
which I expect to probably take it
probably most likely will come from
Vivek could be from Ron D santis and
then you finish your drink anytime a
candidate mentions a Democrat other than
Biden oh gosh I don't know it's gonna
happen a whole lot no yes what are you
talking to mention other Democrats yeah
like who like uh Gavin Newsom Gretchen
Whitmer why would they mention Gavin
news because that's who they're going to
be running against yeah but they're
going to be game fighting tonight it's
going to be Hillary they're going to be
infighting but the the 2020 and Trump
Trump's going to just
are we really gonna do that every time
they mention Trump or drinking yes oh
Lord how about every time somebody
mentions Chris Christie's loves to bib
yeah
what is he going to Gallagher
heavy cream
I think I don't think he needs a bib
anymore they have an IV drip of heavy
cream it is heavy cream it rises to the
top hook it to my veins uh let's go to
this package that you have from one of
our on the ground reporters with Vivek
earlier and then that'll lead us into
our predictions yeah what are your
thoughts on the lockdowns that are
coming right now that they're reported
in the news not going to stand for it
not no Helena hell no yeah how about the
mail-in voting that's going to come
probably after these potential lockdowns
single day voting on Election Day pay
for balance
I've got complaining so the fact that
they're foreshadowing these mask
mandates and everything going on here I
it's a person that struck me as a joke
good
[Applause]
thanks man appreciate it I I do
appreciate first off I appreciate the
baseball cap but I also appreciate that
he gave a straight answer
I like the fact he's holding a baby
nobody know where he got it yeah
[Laughter]
you know for all of the there's so many
people out there who Trump is the only
guy they'll ever look at I'm like look I
get it but there's also got to be
somebody next yeah if he gets elected
it's going to be for four years maximum
vivek's a guy who comes out and gives
you some very he said not only no but
hell no right he gives you a little bit
different answer and it doesn't take a
whole lot to make people go oh good it's
authentic yes well here are a couple of
things that I want to go through by the
way we also do have some other packages
you interviewed Carrie Lake down there
uh we also have Marjorie Taylor green
and a few uh on the ground packages
again with people who will be
interviewing hit the like button tool
man I didn't think you let them know to
comment below and do consider signing up
at my club let's go through uh the
people who are running here who will be
at this debate you have DeSantis you
have Vivek you have Nikki Haley you have
Tim Scott you have Mike Pence Chris
Christie you have uh ice Isa Hutchinson
Hutchinson William we'll call him
William because every time I read it I
think of it as a woman's name you have
uh Doug burgum who is the I know he's
the governor of North Dakota outside of
that no one really cares
but this is what's remarkable here so
who what do I here's one thing that I
think a lot of other people are are
missing and I want to hear from you guys
we'll be reading your chats here today
um everyone talks about Donald Trump not
going to this how that benefits him
right I understand that really if you're
leading by double digits okay I
understand that it's sort of a risk he
doesn't need to take on the flip side
this is such an act of God it is an act
of Mercy a miracle for everyone else
tonight that Donald Trump isn't there
think about it for a second if Donald
Trump showed up the best chance they
have is maybe gaining some traction
right now in his double-digit lead they
would have had no chance if Donald Trump
was there because even if he wasn't
winning he would have burned down the
whole ship think of the primaries that's
when he was the most right it was lowest
low energy low energy Bush small hands
Marco and Ted Cruz your dad killed JFK
whatever you're that day where were you
no one could prepare for it everyone
left with blood on their face the fact
that he isn't there people act as though
Donald Trump is just not taking a risk
for himself why don't we talk about no
one's talking about how much that
benefits all of the other candidates is
it me no no great point I think you're
100 correct like these guys their only
shot is to try to get some traction
tonight and if Donald Trump is there he
sucks all the oxygen out of that place
like everybody's going to be focused on
him yeah you will really have to land
some blows and Donald Trump is so fast
on his feet it's going to be really
really hard for them to do that so I
think you're right like it's a blessing
for them but here's the thing a number
of these guys this may be one and done
for them like they don't have enough
support to make it very far we'll get
into some of the campaign numbers the
percentages of yeah where they stand
they're just terrible with your Morgan
and Coke the drinking game is going to
have you in the ICU for crying out loud
sorry well he's a nice guy warming up I
thought somebody said Christy
you think that it's really going to be
vivex night right I really do I think
it's going to be a big buzz after this
everybody's gonna be talking about my I
sent the guy money
I don't do that you sent Donald Trump
money or visit I sent Trump money to
another thing about it actually I sent
ASA Hudson about 50 bucks too come on to
drop out of the race and uh who else Tim
Scott I sent him buck and a half well no
I sent yeah I sent 25 to vivec uh I just
I I've yet to go this guy he's the most
articulate eloquent like you said he's
put he's balanced he's walking that fine
line right kind of trumpy in in his uh
you know his point in his approach and
people yeah so like that about Ron
DeSantis when we talked about Ron
DeSantis before he declared for
president too yeah by the way just to be
clear I like Rhonda I like Donald Trump
I like Vivek I think he he maybe lacks
some foreign policy experience I would
vote for any of these people against
Biden with the exception of Chris
Christie I would I would write in Nick
de Paulo
um
in a presidential election in
Minneapolis oh well my yeah my dog and
Dean Kane got like 16 000. I'm sorry I
brought that up yeah no I felt guilty
for years
fella
my point is I may have torpedoed an
election with a with a goof
um
I was in Michigan so you know they'll
just find more votes here's one thing
that I think is pretty important though
too A lot of people are saying okay who
can who will win against uh Joe Biden in
general and right now they're saying
well Donald Trump if he's the nominee he
can't win in a general well that's not
really necessarily true against some
context actually matters and I think you
can bring up these overlays Matt we have
uh collage e collage E1 is where we're
going so uh Donald Trump of course been
leading the primary by at least 20
points yeah okay in the primary so it's
really hard for them to make up that Gap
unless there's some kind of a miracle
they're saying that Biden leads Trump in
a head-to-head and that's by the way
only recently by plus one or plus five
now keep in mind up until June Donald
Trump was leading Biden by a couple of
points yeah which was surprising but
let's put this in context if you
actually were to compare Donald Trump
versus Hillary Clinton that this exact
same moment in time going into that 2016
election uh Hillary Clinton was actually
leading him by 10.4 points so not one to
five 10.4 and then if you go into uh
Biden at this exact same point right in
the 2020 polling he was leading Donald
Trump by Plus 12. so a plus one to five
which is pretty new as a development
since June just don't don't let your
primary vote be determined by someone
telling you what the polls are saying
because anyone who would be ahead in the
polls I guarantee you the average would
have them behind Biden and it may or may
not be true but it's not by anywhere
near the margin of the last elections
it's the best margin that you've seen at
this point in time in a campaign in any
of Donald Trump's yeah and it's going to
fluctuate a lot based on what's going on
in the world right so if there seems to
be economic progress which I don't know
where they would get that from but right
now bidenomics is the term it should be
Biden crime family was the term that
everybody was throwing around up there
like this is going to sway people back
and forth for a little bit it's still
very very early once we get into March
and April and May like obviously you're
going to start to see things shake out
considerably by then so I agree my main
point with Donald Trump was if he can
win I'm voting for him because he's got
four years and nothing to lose and day
one he walks into that office and knows
what to do Ron DeSantis as Governor been
fantastic I've liked a lot of what he's
done but day one he walks in and he's
trying to find out where the pencils are
he's just not anybody walking in brand
new is going to have a little bit of a
okay how do I do this where do I go what
do I do Donald Trump won't and he's got
some scores to settle I don't want this
to turn into like political Tit for Tat
I don't want to go after him prosecute
other opponents just because they
prosecuted us I want to set thank you I
kind of do though I don't because
it ends up in a genocide I don't want
that for all the better yeah I mean
we're more prepared we are the party
that does have most of the guns and so
if it ever does come to it we'll be fine
I just I just want him to go in and go
you know what FBI you don't exist
anymore we're putting a under
construction sign on you for just a
little while right and doj yeah we've
got some people to clean out there as
well I think he walks in and does that I
don't think Ron DeSantis does yeah I
think he could be right what about Vivek
about Flying V the Flying V is hilarious
I don't think foreign policy in in this
case I don't think his foreign policy
issues are going to be bad Donald Trump
didn't have a lot of foreign policy
awareness at the time he had business
interactions but the Taiwan China thing
has evolved since then and it's getting
ugly and yeah made a nice statement
today about something about wiping off
the Earth
and of course CNN girls you know yeah
yeah you really mean that oh yeah the
chick with Harry foreign
they've brushed her up a little bit
since the town hall with Trump what they
do shaver
waxing I do believe is the term Nick
waxing Napalm yes uh no so Vivek too
he's gotten under he's gotten some flag
reports saying oh he's a 911 truther
again if you look at his answers to the
questions he never said that night level
was inside job he said we were lied to
by the commission report he said that we
were lied to in the sense that we were
told that the Saudis weren't involved at
all isn't it kind of crazy because I
don't know if you remember this but
there was a man
I believe is Michael Moore and uh he did
a whole film about that and it was a
badge of honor to not believe the George
Bush government George W bush government
narrative 911 and now they're the ones
attacking any Republican nominee as
though there are crazy conspiracy
theorists this is why I say when they
say oh Donald Trump is so bombastic
they're going to make any candidate out
who's the nominee to be dumb or evil it
doesn't matter what you do now they're
flopping on the 911 on the 911 issue was
the biggest I think the highest grossing
documentary of all time up until that
point Fahrenheit 911 someone can fact
check me on it and Michael Moore is a
dick he looks like Walter White
transitioning no one likes him but he
was the guy championing their cause and
now Vivek just saying hey you know what
we were lied to about the Saudis and so
I'm saying that this is a reason to
distrust the government they want you to
believe he's a crazy conspiracy theorist
also a crazy conspiracy theorist Alex
Jones who was right about more rollbacks
and masks
tonight I know yeah I would I would boy
would I pay my even a moderator yeah a
moderator we've got about three minutes
and until Trump and uh uh and Tucker
Tucker thank you very much I lost his
name for some reason so do you maybe get
to some reasons why uh Mr Donald yes
that's right again the promo code is
Crowder GOP debate the hashtag is
Crowder GOP debate we'll be taking your
chat smash the rumble button hit the
like and uh we actually do have we have
some exclusive here you know we always
get some exclusives here at letter with
Crowder we have the inside Lane some
people refer to us inside baseball yeah
I don't know because it's a sports
reference uh we actually were sent from
the Trump campaign the top seven plus
one reasons that Donald Trump is not at
the debate tonight
[Music]
the chamber
oh by the way while you guys are
bringing uh maybe ask T I need some of
those eye drops which you can just pop
there because uh I'm coming down with
something a little bit and uh oh no so
these are these seven plus one reasons
that Donald Trump is actually not going
to be at the debate uh tonight the
reasons he gave officially on the record
number seven uh he's golfing poorly lit
still having fewer Strokes than Mitch
McConnell yeah that's
seven plus one reasons that Donald Trump
will not be at the debate tonight you
know what Nick why don't you take a
crack here at number six he's grabbing
Melania by the well you have to
set an appointment for that yeah it
takes some time to morale if you're
doing it right number five five uh
reasons uh that uh actually you know
what you can do this one Gerald that
Donald Trump will not be here at the
debate tonight he would but Chris
Christie ate his debate prep notes oh
well Christy yeah you don't dip them in
gravy though no yeah no potential
sustenance Unturned
would be there but he has a date to play
Pickleball with Stormy Daniels which wow
I don't know what pickleball is exactly
I assume he'd be throwing a pickle down
a hallway no I don't think so oh in this
situation
top reasons that Donald Trump again that
he officially gave our uh production
managers here who've done a fantastic
job will not be the debate uh number
three he would but he has a private
lesson with Dr Ben Carson on quote how
to keep his pimp hands strong
you have to brush up on that yeah
um I'm black and I don't even know what
that means well you know I spent I was
raising a generation of enter the
Wu-Tang number two Nick I think this
one's up your alley he'll be in Fulton
County Georgia tonight looking for those
11 000 votes
wait a minute that's the Bud Light
Warehouse
[Music]
right yeah someone could bring it up Kid
Rock somebody set him up no the
paparazzi had he was just drinking a Bud
Light and set himself up there's no
reason oh come on that's almost like
taking it back I know I know I might
just have some have some courage here to
your convictions that really hurts me
you need to get drunk do you know what
he was listening to it was bad music
okay well you wanna you said if any band
Dead or Alive you could see would be
Motley Crue so you're one that's not
true at all what are you talking about I
don't understand that's true there it is
right there photoshopped yeah you are
one pathetic you want to believe some
lesbian you're like that tween who still
believes in Santa but you know that it's
not really true but we were keeping an
eye on the on the the Twitter the the
thing that used to be called Twitter to
make sure actually you guys know comes
on we will seven plus one reasons that
Donald Trump has not made the debate
stream tonight number one uh he's sick
his best friend's sister's boyfriend's
brother's girlfriend heard from this guy
who knows this dude who's going with the
girl who saw Trump pass out at 31
Flavors last night
I guess it's not serious I guess it's
pretty serious and the plus one reason
that uh Donald Trump will not be at the
debates tonight uh grand jury duty that
has been this week seven plus one
[Music]
in the chamber Gerald brief us really
quickly I gotta all right so Donald
Trump so it looks like
I have no idea so it looks like they
uploaded the full video One Tim why
don't you go and see if we can bring
that up
um yeah really quickly here
they're smiling that's great thanks for
joining us thank you why aren't you at
the Fox News debate tonight in Milwaukee
well you know a lot of people have been
asking me that and many people said you
shouldn't do them but you see you always
said other people right other people
leading by 50 and 60 points 40. and you
know some of them are at one and zero
and two
for an hour or two hours whatever it's
going to be and uh get harassed by
people that shouldn't even be running
for president should I be doing that and
a network that isn't particularly
friendly to me so that's not live it was
an upload yeah so they're just doing it
as an uploader yeah so we've got our
team going through to get clips and by
the way I can fact check that as true by
the way just to be clear Fox News has
been anti-trump for a significant period
of time and now they're kind of turning
onto santis a little bit but uh they uh
they definitely have been actively
campaigning against Trump well she's the
thing I don't just be honest about it
yep just be honest about it honest about
it I asked you why uh probably they said
the Murdoch sons are very establishment
I remember when you know I worked at I
was at Fox News for four and a half
years and Romney was their guy when is
there no money in Trump is that the
bottom line the bottom Line's the bottom
line and news on TV I think that they
think they can sort of it can be a
coordination because Fox News has had a
has had a sort of a Stranglehold on that
market for a long time so they think
they can get away with it yeah but uh
let's continue listening to Donald Trump
I did that I'm grateful that you did um
it's interesting though because you
spent a lot of your career in television
yeah
but you don't feel the need now running
for president to do television obviously
do you think television is declining
well according to uh polls well that's a
layup it just came out
according to Neil Nielsen
absolutely
just lost credibility
you see or as they say msdnc is so bad
it's so wrong what they write and what
they do and what they say it's you know
it's fake news as I said I think I came
up with that term I hope I do
they say you
say it's terms by the way the drinking
game rules do not apply to this
interview by the way this drink sort of
at this point I guess yeah my throat's
killing me come on
CNN who's absolutely doing no ratings at
all I mean let me smell your drink but
they're doing nothing
wrong
something's just like strong perfumey I
think it's the spice rum
and all of a sudden you're we're doing
this interview but we'll get bigger
ratings using this crazy Forum that
you're using then probably uh probably
the debate or competition well again
it's not really a fair Apples to Apples
to an upload and again impressions are
not the same as views but I guarantee
you that he will have more views but if
you see like 100 million with tuck or
something like that it's it's not the
same as live viewers yeah so sometimes
they'll pull that trick but it is true
that cable news is dying it is dying and
this is one of we talked about that up
there this is one of the first events
where you're seeing them die and Rumble
and places like that are going to take
them out put the nail in the coffin boys
and to be clear by the way about Fox you
have Brett Bear he's obviously running
the uh the debate there tonight along
with Martha McCallum and uh he did say
that January 6th the Committee hearing
made Donald Trump look horrific
apparently there have been a lot of
reports that there's a soft ban on
Donald Trump at Fox News yeah uh they
were really going hard on him because
they were being sued by Dominion they
were all in on DeSantis but now he's not
doing so well they're sort of backing
off a little bit so there is a very
strong bias at Fox News I saw it when I
was there for Mitt Romney as well
which was just in my opinion quite dumb
that he was the guy they're not doing
that well because also Tucker's not
there yeah well that's a big component
yeah they're going to try to put
somebody else in that slot obviously and
see if they can like move people around
but it's it's dying media like people
they look at Willie Nelson they're
watching our show they're watching this
right now they'll be watching the stream
on Rumble like that is taking over media
so here I don't want to talk over Trump
too much oh here we go it is now the
is this live that's live yeah all right
well let's switch from Tucker to the
debates right now coming in from Fox
News this is being live streamed from
Rumble bring up the volume
here there is one Battleground that may
be harder to win than ever
estate known for its beer and cheese
Gridiron and grit and also it's razor
thin elections in 2016 Republicans
narrowly flipped the badger state red
for the first time since Ronald Reagan
yeah who did that by the way
it's not razor thin Wisconsin was in
fact a blue State until Donald Trump
flipped it I lived it that night I was
the second time around this thing in the
suburbs of Milwaukee the division seemed
deeper than ever
but that was just the beginning two
years later the U.S Supreme Court struck
down Roe versus Wade leaving the
legality of abortion up to the states in
Wisconsin that meant a nearly total ban
while they do the intros do you want to
do you want to go over obviously the
opening statements we'll we'll be back
there but do you want to go back to
Trump for a minute yeah let's go back to
Donald Trump I think there's perfume in
my beer geez does that not smell like
perfect bring up Trump it's the new PA
the death of well you drink one of those
fruity on the election fraud either okay
he said he did and he pretended he did
but he didn't uh McSwain the U.S
attorney in Pennsylvania Philadelphia uh
said borrow a bar just wouldn't let him
do it it was crazy Barr became so
petrified so frightened of being
impeached I'm going to impeach him I
don't know if you remember it yeah it's
not a big moment in history they said
we're going to impeach you know they
play a much rougher game than left the
lunatics and they were going to impeach
Bill Barr and he was petrified now how
do you not get impeached don't do any of
this stuff but he didn't do the job
there so we're gonna go back to those
highlights let's go right now they are
introducing the debates we have Brett
Baer and Martha McCallum now is that is
that burgum no uh I can't see oh there's
Mike way down on one end he's a dick
there's Burger all the way on the road
yeah he's playing basketball does the
guy looks like that guy he was a
basketball player all right let's see
I'm at the Macau I tell you what though
Brett Faire will never go bald he has a
hairline like Curious George
for president will accept the party's
nomination next summer
by The order they sit in the polls
in the middle standing Center Stage
understand
it's just sanctimonious
just that smile is off-putting
is my primary care position
[Laughter]
hey Nikki Haley looks good tonight
[Applause]
and there he is Mr Ed's teeth
it's quiet
he looks a little bit like a a a
skinnier Muppet like Scorsese
we'll ask the questions and then
candidates get one all right why they
say this just so you know for the Trump
thing you're not missing anything our
team is actually going through right now
and pulling some of the best moments
from here pulling all the moments we get
those Rumble them in you don't have to
go anywhere to see all of it we will
make sure you see yes absolutely we'll
make sure you see that and cover this
live so tonight
again you can use the hashtag Critter
GOP debate or that promo code to get ten
dollars off mug Club right now as long
as this is live let's hear the stupid
questions at a time when the likely
Democrat nominee President Joe Biden is
working to convince the country that
with bidenomics things are looking up
economics
I'm not sure that many of them totally
complimentary way at the time
but guess what it's
wow but is it the American Rescue plan
is what 1.9 trillion the inflation
reduction next 500 billion the
bipartisan infrastructure law 1.2
trillion chips and science act 278
billion dollars and we've had the worst
inflation since actually surpassing
Jimmy Carter this is an easy easy layup
I hope they get into specifics let's go
to the guy in the Michael Jordan had a
lot of people's out here homeless
because they came back
down versus two to three it's just you
can't afford a house anymore it's
inflation is ridiculous it's killing us
off that's not your biggest problem
we sit here tonight the number one song
on the Billboard Chart is
north of Richmond
It Is by a singer from Farm this is a
weird way to lead it's a very weird
his lyrics speak of alienation that's
Tupac one said in his album All Eyes On
Me
of this country
Washington D.C is about a hundred miles
north of Richmond
[Music]
this is like an award show yeah yeah
what the hell yeah exactly and now up
for song Chris Christie looks hungry I'm
not even joking yeah
he looks like he's looking they don't
feed him this country singer like a guy
in a stranded Island when you turn into
like a roast chicken yeah yeah he's a
drumstick these guys are probably
hearing the song for the first time yeah
they're like Richmond north of Richmond
that's us yeah exactly
singing about us striking such a nerve
in this country right now what do you
think it means our country is in Decline
this decline is not inevitable it's a
choice that's so rigid it almost seems
back to his basement and reverse
American decline
was that a planned Applause because he
hasn't said anything good yet standing
we must Reverse by Dynamics so that
middle class families have a chance to
succeed again we cannot succeed as a
country if you are working hard and you
can't afford groceries a car or a new
home while Hunter Biden can make
hundreds of thousands of democrators not
Joe Biden Hunter Biden that is wrong I'm
not finishing my drink though we also
cannot succeed when the Congress spends
trillions and trillions of dollars those
rich men north of Richmond have put us
in this situation and finally we need to
lower your gas prices we're going to
open up all energy production we will be
energy dominant again in this country so
you know someone said come out
forcefully you know come out forcefully
and so I think it was in the military so
yeah he's a leader he's a bond leader he
confused forceful for loud
and now it goes back to that anyway
Governor Christie do you agree with
Governor DeSantis just said there and
why would you be better why Christy next
just laid out I think that if you asked
every one of us up here that we would
agree predominantly with what he just
laid out here's the difference the
difference is that we're going to have
to work and make sure that we sell these
ideas and we're able to be able to put
ourselves in a position where we get a
majority of the votes like you sold
two-lane traffic on your bridge and
in the 24 but also by having someone
who's had the experience of doing it now
I was elected as a conservative you mean
president Trump in a blue State no no
let's correct that phrase you were
elected as a republican let's not say
Conservative Republican in in a blue
state which means you're not a
republican yeah it's a state where you
can't even pump your own gas Jesus
Jersey brought them around to our point
of view we cut taxes in New Jersey
probably cutting cars
we closed roads in New Jersey we were
confronted with bad Democratic ideas we
stood and stopped them and when there
were good ideas we brought people
together to make progress going for one
second I'm gonna take a bite of myself
truth and accountability are the things
we need to do to fight waste and I'd say
the last thing is this Brad we cannot
sit by any longer and allow the kind of
spending that's going on in Washington
because every dollar they spend is a
dollar that these people are not allowed
to spend on their children and their
grandchildren it's robbing our country
and it's wrong well Governor let me just
follow up very quickly New Jersey
had the second lowest credit rating in
the nation after Illinois and it was
well that's not his fault I mean His
Highest BMI yes and that's what happens
when you inherit a blue state that has
done that but when you look at what we
did on dead bread in that state we cut
debt in that state debt that had been
Left To Us by three cut the crust off
your sandwiches predecessors of mine who
ran up that debt I think we're going to
get him for the Post debates and get
that off there was to cut the
unemployment rate in half it was over 10
percent when I became governor in 2010
what we also did was cut pension
payments to public employees to make
sure that taxpayers were not being so
apparently none of that worked because
you're still second to last
killing the taxpayers how's that for a
follow-up but when it comes to being
second to last we're tops yeah
after welfare program Pizza as a senator
Senator President Biden argued for
freezing federal spending this is back
that's a nice jacket why are you wearing
a photo negative of the Thriller jacket
he does not talk about that
you've been a senator though for 10
years so what have you done to reign in
please lead your answer
hey come on man
over the last several years I've had an
opportunity to vote against a spending
package after spending package after
spending package but we also need to
understand is that Joe Biden's Biden
nomics has led to the loss of ten
thousand dollars of spending power for
the average family when you see 16
inflation your gas is up 40 percent your
food actually have the numbers right
here on the uh the bidenomics as far as
how much more you're spending uh which
which paid is by Dynamics here I have in
my prep I always do this at the very
back second right keep the volume there
up there Tim let me just say this Chris
Christie had the lowest approval rating
ever for a New Jersey governor at 15
percent I'm sure that's going to come I
wouldn't talk about that's because of
the Democrats as he would tell you yes
so uh you were spending 202 dollars more
in July by the way in just one year than
you would have uh to buy goods or
services one year ago 709 dollars more
than two years ago it has crippled
Americans the inflation just you know
that's one thing that's not a talking
point but everyone has that arrow in
their quiver let's go back to Mr Scott
for the American people okay but just to
follow up you did during the Trump
Administration you approved uh Trump's
mentioned wow
1.7 trillion over the course of that
Administration that's a lot of money
there's no doubt that during the year
right when we were dealing with the
Covenant experts we spent more money but
here's what happened at the end of our
time in the majority we had low
unemployment record low unemployments
three and a half percent for the
majority of the population 70 70-year
low for women
African-Americans Hispanics and Asians
had a all-time low but our influence
where the white women at two percent
under Joe Biden we've seen the exact
opposite we've seen inflation explode
which led to 12 Federal Reserve
increases that's devastating home buyers
today
Mr ramaswamy you're listening
was there a buzzer yeah
I'll be with you in a second Mr vice
president Mr ramaswamy oh we just shut
down can I talk he just rolled up a
newspaper and spanked Mike Pence's dog
in front of the drink does that count as
a moderator
cut off drink 38 years old uh you've
said that yeah two presidential
elections before this moment this
political race
so first let me just address a question
that is on everybody's mind at home
tonight yes my hair is real who the heck
is this skinny guy with a funny last
name and what the heck is he doing in
the middle of this debate stage I'll
tell you I'm not a person I think people
thought why is tech support here I'm an
entrepreneur my parents came to this
country with no money 40 years ago
I talked to him on the phone last night
blazing R2 too
I didn't hear it sorry that was the
American dream good and I am genuinely
worried that that American Dream will
not exist for our two sons
that's the issue this is this is kind of
like an opening speech which is fine he
needs to do that but then he needs to
Pivot into answering the question who
have been running from something
now is Our Moment to start running to
something to our vision of what it means
to be an American it's got a lot of fans
he's the guy keys to the people who
broke it again you hand it over to a new
generation to actually fix the problem
that's why I'm in this race and we're
just getting warmed up
why are you better position to turn
around this economy that we've heard all
of these voters talking about tonight
then Mr ramaswamy who is a successful
entrepreneur nationally right now he's
beating you in the polls well I don't
care about polls what I care about the
fact is that no one is telling the
Americans the truth is that Biden didn't
do this to us
when they passed that 2.2 trillion
dollar coveted stimulus it's valid
points I don't like it but 90 million
people on Medicaid 42 million people on
food stamps no one has told you how to
fix it I'll tell you how to fix it they
need to stop the spending they need to
stop the borrowing they need to
eliminate the earmarks that the
Republicans brought back in and they
need to make sure they understand these
are taxpayer dollars it's not theirs I
notice you've had yours pinned right
Haley to you Christian Scott
female president with the black
stripper's first name what
Chandelier
at the end of the day you look at the
2024 budget Republicans asked for 7.4
billion in earmarks Democrats asked for
2.8 billion so you tell me who are The
Big Spenders I think it's time for an
accountant in the White House vice
president Pence
and that brings us to Mike Pence
speaking of boring here's where the
Democrats are different Mike Pence
cannot have a good performance tonight
I'm calling it right now and again you
can send in your predictions it's not
possible for him he's awful if you did
it wouldn't matter no
but as vice president your
Administration spent more than any prior
7.8 trillion dollars added to the
national debt 3.5 trillion of that
before covet I'm proud does that mean
that you're part of the spending that
does mean half years that's a pretty big
number for letting me respond let me ask
you a question Mike can you find a
dipstick
I'm incredibly proud of the record of
the Trump Pence Administration
in four short years we rebuild our
military we revived our economy we
unleash American Energy
Martha you asked earlier who's
who's most best
I'm gonna tell you with all due respect
to all of my friends Donald Trump and
even the one that's probably looking on
I think unquestionably I am the best
prepared
I led Indiana where we balance budgets
and had a triple a bond rating but he
certainly would make a great Judas
before
people to Indiana might deliver I know
right it's scary to be clear
there's two Judas
in a hundred years all that being said I
was the first person in this race to say
that we've got to deal with the
long-term national debt issues look at
his res his resume is I have more
experience because I was tapped to bvp
no one actually voted then he goes I was
the first to you were the first
Republican to say that we need to lower
spending dummy there's nothing you need
this is the thing with with Mike Pence
he will say whatever he thinks is
necessary it is talking points
personified I don't think I've ever is
it just me he doesn't have an original
thought no it just doesn't he when
people talk about politicians who are
rinse recycle repeat they're just
they're specific referring to Mike Pence
that's right he's the guy I see 1980
they're trying to jump in let's see I'm
gonna give back first this isn't that
complicated guys unlock American energy
drill Frack burn coal Embrace nuclear I
love he said burn call I love it yes
they're paying them more to stay at home
stabilize the US dollars he's from the
town where October Sky was based on that
I will declare as U.S president will be
the war on the federal administrative
state that is the source of those toxic
regulations acting like a wet blanket on
the economy so I'm not sure I exactly
understood Mike Pence's comment but I'll
let you all parse that out for me it's a
pretty simple good way to call them
honest president with focus and I'll
deliver on it you know what I like about
him too he's not doing the thumb BS he's
pointing that's he's pointing like a
good Indian should you know I sometimes
struggle with the reading look I was uh
I was a house conservative leader before
it was cool
I balance budgets and cut taxes when I
was governor I mean look Joe in Indiana
this country at home and abroad now is
not the time for on-the-job training we
don't need to bring it there's this bug
where he really thought on the job
whoa we need new blood Mike look at even
dress like this what about I mean I take
on the job training over on the job
failing Mike yes yes there's no question
mark with you it's a guarantee he talks
like he was the president I know
federal government handed covid-19 by
locking down into this economy it was a
mistake it's not to sound like Paul
Lyndon when he gets excited I'm telling
you how to lock down we kept our state
free and open that's a very strong point
though for Ron DeSantis he should point
to him being one of the I think really
two places if I'm not mistaken that did
it right as far as right away on he was
the first state to open back up repeal
lockdowns this is a strong point for him
and I hope he goes in hard on
immigration because I like how he's
answered that in the past no amnesty he
should lean into that let's see
[Applause]
is pointing too much that's too much of
the point everybody's gotten they're
memorized prepared slogans out of the
way we can actually have a real
discussion now yes
[Applause]
not really Mike actually we're just
gonna have some fun tonight and the
reality is you have a bunch of people
professional politicians Super PAC
puppets following slogans handed over to
them
last week the real choice we face in
this primary is this do you want a Super
PAC puppet or do you want a patriot who
speaks the truth do you want incremental
reform which is what you're hearing
about or do you want Revolution okay
American Revolution we're going to take
control back here we need everybody to
have a moment on the economy yeah I
think that's fair Martha men are talking
here quiet yeah ASA Hudson is uh keep
silence thank you
I'm just glad to be here I can barely
stand I'm on pain meds that blew out my
kids there he is if you watch them on
the stage with all these folks
I'm just happy to be here Bob
Bob with these eyebrows all wishing me
well I think I took them a little too
literally when they said go to Milwaukee
and break a leg
oh boy you can't wait to get that one
stupid tore his Achilles cross him up
now please we can't just talk about that
I was hooping last night economy energy
and National Security are all tied
together we of course we're paying too
much for our energy in our in our state
right in our country right now but part
of the reason why is because the Biden
policies you know his only chance would
have been to come out with all like like
swap Rama Swami did today with you know
double barrel and instead he's coming
out exactly showing us why he shouldn't
be here are they all dressed the same or
am I high what pretty much blue suit
both and you're high buying batteries
from China we're just trading OPEC for
sinopec and then belatedly belatedly the
the bite Administration says no we're
going to put sanctions on Russia
and Henry Winkler had a baby bring up
those pictures that's spot on this
country you buy a solo like an Italian
where it's being powered by oil and gas
at 20 off and every farmer in this
country would like to buy diesel at 20
off just like so this guy said I'm going
to be the energy kid that's right that's
what he said I was just thinking he has
that all the greats have their calling
cards and so do the mediocre oh ASA to
be here today I forgot you were there
let me just you may go this guy nobody
likes Governor from a conservative state
that had a conservative record in which
I lowered taxes yeah it's still a right
Governor I created a two billion dollar
Surplus that I passed over to my
successor and I made sure that we Shrunk
the size of government in Arkansas
fewer state employees in Arkansas
afternoon flipper babies and when I took
over as Governor eight years ago I tell
that because that's what we need in
Washington D.C we need somebody who can
actually constrain the growth of federal
government that can actually reduce the
this is not this is not a race about
just reducing the size and spending of
government yes of course that should be
a given and I get it that Republicans
have spent far too much that is not what
is going to energize the American public
you need to make this about immigration
and about corruption in the government
and the media you need to make it about
the elites just like ramaswamy did right
now Donald Trump could have said that
right it's very simple do you want a
puppet-pack candidate he sounds like
Donald Trump he's tearing a page from
his book because he understands that
that is what mobilizes people not just
talking about deficits yes that does
matter but that's not what you lead with
if you need to get ahead and get
American people the American public to
actually start paying attention to you
and especially since you've been in
Congress for the last 20 years exactly
out of the problem exactly why is it
spending out of control what have you
done you know well just give us give us
the the control let me hear the Brett
Bear what's his question after the
deadliest U.S wildfire and we're back
why is governor and White House
officials said that climate change
Amplified the cost of human error and a
tropical storm hit California for the
first time in 84 years the ocean hits
Fox News actually trying to Parrot the
idea that it's climate change it sounded
like that a little bit let me see let me
see how little we should be able to
trust them is from Young Americas
Foundation has a question for you all
polls consistently show that young
people's number one issue is climate
change how will you as both president of
the United States and leader because
they don't know any party I'm really
curious to see the answer please SWAT it
out of hand and point out that the
warning didn't work that the water
didn't work that all of their fail-safes
didn't work and that the with the guy
who was it was the coroner from Vegas
the Vegas shooting for criminal please
clarify this children let's have the
debate I mean I'm happy to take it to
start Alexander so do you want to raise
your hand or not I don't think that's
the way to do so let me just say to
Alexander this first of all one of the
reasons our country's decline is because
of the way the corporate media treats
Republicans versus Democrats Biden was
on the beach while those people were
suffering he was asked about it he said
no comment are you kidding me as
somebody that's handled disasters in
Florida you got to be activated you've
got to be there you've got to be present
you've got to be helping people who are
doing this and here's the deal girls
being beaten in the audience can you
answer the question about climate change
because we want to guide this yeah he's
already able to sabotage everybody the
the moderator
stage who isn't bought and paid for so I
can say bring up the drinking game rules
again
agenda
wet blanket on our economy and so the
reality can you bring up the drinking
game rules climate change policies
anytime Trump has mentioned January 6
was mentioned moderator Interruption
candidate a thug life moment finish your
drink as I mentioned Democrat other than
Biden
listen listen
I've had enough already Mr French of a
guy who sounds like Chachi BT standing
oh you stole that from a funny meme you
read on Fortune you fat son of a the
last person in one of these debates
Brett who stood in the middle of the
stage and said what's a skinny guy with
an odd last name doing up here Obama was
Barack Obama and I'm afraid we're
dealing with the same type of amateur
standing Sage tonight oh that's not
going to help you Chuckles
say the word bully Chris you big girl
hold on hold on
here
is it just me and by the way hit the
like button if you're watching this on
YouTube or if you're watching I never
think that Chris they say he's he's a
tough talker you know he comes across as
incredibly feminine to me yes he's a
whiny he's
cat-picked on as fat as a kid and he
still has that mentality yeah he should
have gotten ripped he's a big girl who
loves every hand in the bully's face
Charles clean air clean water we want to
see that taken care of but there's a
right way to do it and the right way to
do it is first of all stop by burning
that jacket yes it is but if you want to
go and really change the environment
then we need to start telling China and
India oh boy oh wow oh what just
happened is that good buffering oh there
he is back that's where our problem is
and these green subsidies that Biden has
put in all he's done is helped China
because he doesn't understand all these
electric vehicles that he's done with
that can someone bring up actually uh
Mission Control bring this up you should
be able to get this in about 15 seconds
uh Biden just removed I think was it 10
or 15 uh companies from The Blacklist
from China just did just today I believe
it was yesterday that he did it the last
day or two yeah it was in the last day
or two because we're sending an Envoy
over there right now yeah exactly in
anticipation of that I'll have to keep
appearances up in China you've got to
stop polluting and that's
[Applause]
absolutely not I mean here's what the
American people deserve is a debate
about the issues that affect their lives
going back and forth being childish is
not helpful to the American people to
decide
yeah exactly
there you go the single parent household
Martin Show me your gums what's the
American dream real for kids who were
devastated by poverty devastated by the
challenges of life I came to the
conclusion that America can do for
anyone what she's done for me if we
focus on restoring hope creating
opportunities and protecting America if
we what are the drinking game rules for
an anti-thrug life moment I think Tim
Scott has you get to that tonight you
could drink yeah you know what though
the only person who said no no we're not
doing the climate change things the only
person was Vivek so good for him yeah
maybe he's saying what people want to
hear but at least he's willing to speak
out everyone else is we shouldn't be
childish China and India what are you
going to do about that Nikki because you
were ambassador to the U.N who by the
way they ignored yeah all right sorry
that was having a Larry Elder moment has
cut our carbon footprint in half in the
last 25 years the places where they are
continuing to increase Africa 950 at
some point India over a billion China
over a billion why would we put
ourselves at a disadvantage
devastating our own economy let's bring
our jobs look here's what you do finish
the line of questioning Republic why
would we put our here's what you do you
say why does the Biden Administration
want to put us at a disadvantage to
these countries that want to see us fail
places like China right these great
polluters out there who have no
intention of honoring these
International agreements what sort of
will the American economy that's
right because they're not looking out
for you they're not looking out for the
American people they're looking out for
internal International interests because
they're bought and paid for we can talk
about uh Joe Biden's connections with
the Chinese government he's talked about
it quite a bit we can talk about their
connections with Ukraine if you want to
understand why we've dedicated 135
billion dollars I know we haven't spent
it all yet but
answer
answer that's the guy who's going to win
this that's the guy who's going to make
up some ground I don't know who you guys
are hiring but aside from Vivek tonight
fire them is it just me please send in
your prede send me your comments it
feels very dated their approach yeah and
I've seen this show a thousand times
well and I think we're tired of it right
absolutely tired of hearing these canned
responses and Nikki Haley's like does
climate change exist absolutely well it
depends on what you mean by that right
does man-made climate change exist I
don't know do we have an impact on it
yeah I'm sure to some degree but if you
look at a lot of the science that's
coming out right now that's too much
I'll tell you what you say man-made
climate change what they need is
man-made climate change look maybe
there's some debate about that but about
which there can be no debate is Joe
Biden can't fix it
there you go
then you expand upon you expand upon if
you have that time but the point is
people and I because you're you're I get
it you're nerdy Soul mine a little bit
but guess what people you only have a
few seconds to punch in and punch out
but if you're so busy tripping over
yourself and your advisors talking
points to get to something prefab you're
never going to connect with the people I
get it you think Donald Trump's
bombastic but you know what bombastic is
better than completely inauthentic the
only people here tonight who have a
remote chance have been Vivek and
potentially Ron D santis but he also
needs to just relax a little bombastic
one twice by the way we probably
actually they gave us that it was
actually dozens of companies that were
dozens of companies I thought it was 15.
yeah so
um but also we may have some clips from
Trump Tim Tillman do you have any of
those over there and Trump with Tucker
Carlson
and then we do have a we actually have
our on the ground correspondent Finnegan
who's actually out there uh today at the
uh the RNC division wow they give me a
lot of questions
the first one off the top let's all
right let's run these now these are the
highlights from uh Donald Trump and
Tucker Carlson as they are at commercial
break with the RNC debate bye
there you go that's a war that should
end immediately not because of one side
or the other because hundreds of
thousands of people are being killed can
you imagine
and Rockets are going into that building
and blowing it up and knocking it down
and
who who can why why should anything why
should anybody human beings is a human
whether they're Russian or Ukrainian or
whatever they are
it's got to be stopped and it can't be
stopped very easily she would have never
started if I were president
it would have never served now I can
tell you exactly what the media is going
to say oh he equivocated between you
innocent ukrainians and evil Russians
are gonna say Donald Trump said Russians
just like Ukraine which of course is
horseshit he's a guy who's saying we
shouldn't have a war
I can tell you exactly what the media is
going to do come back tomorrow tell me
if I'm wrong on that clip do we have
context for the next clip that we can
run a little bit sorry I just get so
angry when I watch something and I know
that it's a losing play yeah and this is
what hey you know what you know what the
problem is you want to know what a
little bit of the problem is is the fact
that these people are always holding the
same non-profit donors why do you think
that yaf gets the first question why do
you think it was a layup for climate
change
I like I like a lot of people yeah just
to be clear I like a lot of people at
these non-profits but the billions of
dollars Ironically in the free
enterprise capitalist movement
unfortunately the purse strings are held
by non-profit donors who are out of
touch with the American public sure
they'll talk about Trump when it's
convenient for clicks
but why was yaf asking a question about
climate change at the RNC debate how
many things how many trains did not run
on time for that to happen yeah
exactly by the way just so you know the
debate is taking a break right now
that's why yeah
just want to make sure that you guys
know that but we do have some more uh
Trump Clips there and I think they are
labeled by what they're talking about at
least all right uh see second one
talks about Biden talks about Joe won't
make it let's see this one Joe won't
make it so bad he's the worst president
in the history of our country
I don't think he's going to make it to
the gate but you know you never know
but he's a corrupt person so corrupt
that I took the name of Hillary you know
I don't do two people at one time I took
the crook of Hillary and I made it I
retired the net it was a good day for
her I bet she was very happy and I used
it for Joe because it's crooked Joe but
Joe is really you don't think he's gonna
make it to November of 20. well I think
he's worse mentally than he is
specifically
that's what Gerald thinks too a
triathlete he's not going to be there
and you guys can comment especially if
you're watching right now on mug Club if
you're not a member we'll go to Mud Club
exclusively with some interviews from
candidates today live.com uh everyone
here aside from me thinks that the
nominee for the Democrats will not be
Joe Biden let me know what you think
let's go right now they're asking uh
Nikki Haley a question
apologetically polite if not because the
Republican Party tells me to be but
because my husband was adopted and I had
trouble having both of my children so
I'm surrounded by blessings having said
that we need to stop demonizing this
issue this is talking about the fact
that unelected justices didn't need to
decide something this personal because
it's personal for every woman and man
now it's been put in the hands of the
people I've got to tell you it's great
when it comes it really seems like Fox
News is trying to set up these people to
fail asking a leading question about the
abortion issue because they see that
that's been a losing issue on the state
level with people not understanding
Heller versus DC in the overturns and uh
same thing right there when they're
asking about climate change it's like
I'm not what it's like I'm watching CNN
or MSNBC I don't know it's just what I'm
seeing right now let's hear her finish
her answer abortion shouldn't have to
perform them can't we all agree that
contraception should be available and
can't we all agree that we are not going
to put a woman in jail or give her the
death penalty if she gets an abortion no
one is saying that no one is saying that
boom that's a wolf in sheep's clothing
right there her using that talking point
point me to one governor who's saying
that a woman should get a death penalty
for having an abortion performed if she
is raped there's not one person saying
that it's like she took that straight
out of Salon or slate or insert your
shitty blog here
what do you say to him and others who
say politically that is a tough thing to
sell now you know actually really
quickly let's go live to our on the
ground correspondent actually he's out
there right he's gotten some interviews
yeah uh Thomas Finnegan he's down there
do we have him yes we okay because this
is a boring question right now if
they're asking and it's a it honestly is
a setup I don't want to play these games
let's go right now
[Music]
all right Mr Finnegan big night what do
you got for us hi Stephen I'm ready to
go yeah wait where are Mike Pence's
bathroom why hiding out I'm gonna get
you a candid exclusive interview are you
are you out of your mind how did he get
past security jail
how did I just walked in I don't think
they like him very much
wait I gotta go I hear someone coming
[Music]
thank you
I'm sorry about that Nick you deserved
better maybe maybe not I don't think we
should ever expect better from Thomas
Finnegan but you called it where is
something like that coming from an
article from Salon SC GOP bill would
subject to those obtaining abortions to
the death penalty there you go yeah how
do I know it's almost like I've done
this for a while and Nikki Haley's yes
all right let's go back to Ron D Santos
hey Mike Pence is talking let's go let's
all hurry so we can not care well look
I'm
I'm not new to this cause
I tell you what you are new too Jesus
Christ as my Lord and Savior I open up
the book and I read yeah then as before
I formed you in the womb I knew you and
by the way I agree with all the the but
this is not the first debate should not
be about the abortion issue for these
candidates and the way they framed the
question was obviously one trying to get
people to slip up
um I get that Mike Pence is trying to
position himself as a social
conservative which I am through and
through I could I'm as pro-life as you
get but this the line of questioning
tonight do not be fooled climate change
is the most discussed issue in our
generation and then the next question
after that are two questions later is
the abortion issue that's being
misrepresented this is going to tell you
who your friends are when you look at
people like Nikki Haley and how they
answer I guarantee that Mike Pence has a
good answer but this is not this is a
no-win situation for these people this
early in a campaign you know what they
won't ask they won't ask a single
Democrat to put a limit on abortion not
one that'll never happen hey let's say
it's not nine months when is it is it
eight is it seven is it six and you'll
find out really quickly who has a more
reasonable policy I'm just really
disappointed that Fox News is doing this
but I guess I shouldn't be surprised
nobody's talking about abortion I read
the headlines every day for the last two
months well one person is a salon Fox
News who's well that's what I'm saying
I'm validating you no I haven't heard
anybody mention a book about the
illegals I was distracted looking for a
fly on Mike Pence's hair yeah to see if
that oh yeah no his hair is actually
just a bunch of deceased flies
he got him
there's any more than a Democrat
president could ban all those state laws
don't make women feel like they have to
decide on this issue when you know we
don't have 60 Senate votes in the house
victim do not you don't have a vagina no
opinion really all right you know what
there's never been a male president so
you can't run
of those sorry female president yeah
let's get Governor Burgman for one one
minute here for anything so so do you
really think you have a shot yes what
are you doing here stupid the result of
that decision was that it went to the
states
so that's where it is right now
there you go Henry Winkler and there it
is yeah he's the Italian Transylvania
about the states there's about five of
them including New Jersey I think uh a
few others
that allow abortion up until the time of
birth
would you should be third grade what cut
first of all I'm getting the governor of
a very pro-life state
and this issue is of course very
important but I am on the record and I
stand behind
that we should not have a federal
abortion ban uh we should not and the
reason why we shouldn't is very simple
there is a federal abortion ban though
in the Constitution there is no federal
abortion no he's saying that they're
basically pushing for it that's what the
argument was with Nikki Haley and Mike
Pence right pushing for a federal
abortion ban and he's saying look that's
a state's rights issue right he just
pulled out a little Constitution flask
oh geez people we need to be tough to
drink from with this for the people in
this country that man owns no upper lip
we can't have Republicans who fight for
50 years for this great cause and when
to return it back to the States and then
the next day they turn around and go no
the feds should do that because the feds
are stepping into people's lives they're
stepping people's businesses over and
over again and as someone who does who
does do it as a termination of a life I
also unders this is the this is the
middle ground that people talked about
that Republicans need to take it goes to
the states I understand people making
the argument yeah but murder is illegal
on a federal level I understand but as
far as what you can accomplish
politically
this is about as good as you're going to
get in states can enact their laws and
then you do a better job of doing that
within their states but this is not a
fair question and also credit where
credit's due Nick you kind of nailed it
with the flask Constitution I didn't
even know that was a thing but I guess
that's the
but he can't purse his lip up against
it'll just dribble right down to his
underpants this is the guy out of all of
this making me laugh that he even he's
dead and I know out of there well he is
his name a lefty uh Chris Christie the
term so they have their extreme position
at a national level we it's most likely
going to be addressed in this stage but
it's certainly fine is most likely going
to be addressed
we ate with the Confederacy
I signed 30 pro-life pieces of
legislation while I was governor 30 and
how many does it take exactly I thought
it was one thank you and it is the most
important issue for women and for the
unborn child and for our country that we
get this right hold on it's not just for
women anymore abortion that's true
that's true I'm telling you men can have
abortions too absolutely yeah I mean
your prostate won't be the biggest fan
of it but you don't even have to go to
Planned Parenthood you just play
football with your buddies in a better
kid that's a few get blindsided
and Timmy ends up there anyway the
streets we've done in Arkansas and are
important for our nation's future
football and Bobby ended up with a
miscarriage I don't know how that poor
Bobby
like California New York and Illinois
have a boyfriend on I liked him Scott he
just didn't come to play black people
aren't boring how do we pick a boring
black
[Laughter]
people they're interesting people where
do we find this man Carson was
already taken
[Music]
since our creator gave us inalienable
rights that include life
that is a list that is an issue we must
solve we can't leave it to Illinois we
can't leave it oh come on yes you can
why don't you start talking like
Octavius Spencer when she cries I know
we can't
[Music]
even knocking he sounded like Hillary
doing a black guy
because that's
right
ask them the homelessness crisis where's
your limit cities are in Decline people
are moving out as homeless drugs crime
move in uh there are problems
accelerated as drugs and crime have been
Mr Scott you know about that I'm just
joshing you hey ASA Hutchinson this
one's for you
Chicago all up 30 between 2019 and 2022.
homeless the face of the homeless person
I expect for the homeless what is that
vice president a lot of this began in
sir if you wouldn't mind showing your
ass crack next to the big golf don't
worry I'll blow your face happening
around this country is a result of those
coved lockdowns and is your
Administration in part to blame for how
we got here well I think what's in part
to blame is the Democrats been talking
about defunding the police
and we ought to be funding law
enforcement particularly in our major
cities at an unprecedented levels I mean
it's extraordinary to think about the
violence that's claiming innocent lives
literally every week in every major city
in this country and yet Democrats and
liberal prosecutors in major
metropolitan areas continue to to work
out their fanciful agendas to to do a
bail reform
what we need is is strong because it's
bigger than that Mike it's a cultural
revolution in Washington DC honestly
it'll Marshal the resources of the
state's Marshall the resources he's like
Jiminy Cricket if I could stomp him an
opportunity a lot of people don't know
that those trucks we want to bring up
some of the Trump with the Tucker
interview can somebody that's Flying
Blind I have no idea what's coming up so
I've got plenty of trump stuff just kind
of Feathering it in so here's him
talking about Gavin Newsom oh wonderful
that should be fun
bye Mike
Newsome Newsome we're switching it says
Newsome three it says two three a one
two cutting them we have like Newsome
guys just give us the highlights we
don't have 20 Clips don't cut all of it
okay cut everything uh
um Newsome
all right let's go to Chris Christie
because he's going to say something guys
talking about chicken cacciators
blameless prices on easy access to guns
they also blame Republicans for blocking
gun control legislation
this may be a layup for Chris Christie
to sabotage himself because he's
incredibly anti-gun I'm the only person
along with Governor Hutchinson up on
this stage who's actually running United
States attorney's office I ran the fifth
largest office in America in a state
where there is significant The Oblong
office
did you make it the fifth largest office
exactly more money
the west wings
are refusing to do their job and to
arrest violent criminals so what a
president Christie would do is appoint
an attorney general who would instruct
why didn't if I'm not mistaken why
didn't Governor Christie you guys uh
fact check bring this up for me please
in Mission Control why didn't Governor
Christie get rid of the waiting period I
believe it was 30 days and there was a
woman who actually had a restraining
order out against her ex-husband I
believe or maybe it was her current
fiancee who ended up being killed
because she needed a gun immediately so
when people say why do you need a gun
right away why can't you have a cooling
down period I don't know sometimes
people need to purchase a firearm to
defend themselves for a specific
situation Governor Christie was probably
the most left if I'm not mistaken he's
if there's a rating system probably the
worst Republican governor in the history
of the Second Amendment that's why he
wants to talk about who he appointed
which was mandated by legislation
sponsored by his father and then you
have a justice department that walks
away from those charges in your case
apply to everybody in a Christian
Administration he would go to jail for
10 years what about a president Rama
Swami what is it
good going back
the reality is
he is a tree and we know how to fix it
the question is do we actually have the
spine to do it more cops in the streets
who are on the streets able to do their
jobs without looking over their shoulder
for getting sued and we also have a
mental health epidemic in this country
just over the same period that we have
called Suburban Women Health
institutions we have seen a spike in
violent crime do we have the spine to
bring them back I think we should as
president I will but it's not just
drugging up people in those psychiatric
institutions with Zoloft and Seroquel
it's a deeper issue I think faith-based
approaches can play a really older we're
in the middle of a national identity
crisis and I say this as a member of my
generation the problem in our country
right now the reason we have that mental
health epidemic is that people are so
hungry for purpose and meaning at a time
when Family Faith patriotism hard work
have all disappeared what we really need
is a tonal reset from the top saying
that this is what it means to be an
American yes we will stand for the rule
of law yes we will close the southern
order where criminals are coming in boom
fit it in there good Thug Life moment
first guy to fit an immigration we
remember who we really are and that's
also how we address that mental health
epidemic in the Next Generation that is
directly leading to violent crime
tonight
we're not looking for a new national
identity the American people are the
most faith-filled freedom-loving
idealistic hard-working people the world
has ever known we just need government
as good as our people we don't need
government periods stupid but some
others like you may have on this stage
it's morning in America's speech it is
not morning in America we live in a dark
moment and we have to confront the fact
good internal good and by the way if you
go back to Ronald Reagan everyone acts
like Ronald Reagan was just shining City
on a Hill no at the beginning of his
campaigns he talked about where they
were in that country when he smoked
Carter he talked about the dark days of
America and then transitioned into a
plan Mike Pence is delusional that does
not resonate with the American public
and certainly not people who will vote
for a republican let me
well the Statewide it's a 50-year low
and so here's the thing Brett was too
ready yeah yeah
America's decline in one of the biggest
reasons is because you have George Soros
funding these radical left-wing District
Attorneys they get into office and they
say they're not we all know that what
are you going to do about it they
disagree with the inmates start running
the Asylum there's one guy in this
entire country that's ever done anything
about that me that is true we had two of
these things attorneys in Florida
elected with Soros funding who said they
wouldn't do their job I removed them
from their posts they are gone
boom good Thug Life moment we'll need
some refills on the beers because I know
I'm out yeah that's right
because they are hurting the quality of
life and they are victimizing people and
every corner of this country and it will
stop it okay you were right on Chris
Christie it was a 30-day waiting period
and there was a woman who was killed wow
while waiting on her gun permit for
protection
that's probably what does that that's
going back to Obama days it is 2000 and
actually 2015 not gonna go 15. yeah so
good job guys
comes together and helps him get the
excuse me Dracula's talking there's
transparency one thing
and small town values
to get this country on track again we
can do it in North Dakota look at that
smile
[Laughter]
he looks like he they're probably red
yes usually and he has a tail yeah he
does well that's really more of a growth
of the coccyx bone tailbone but these
are medical terms
[Music]
with my left hand thanks to balancing
our agency inner cities as president of
the United States
I couldn't do this one it starts at the
top I rubbed one out today in the
uh
indictment is undermined by attacking
judges by attacking prosecutors by
attacking this this week I'm sorry
and so we have to have respect no
seriously we're not like he isn't
actually paralyzed on his right side
right like we're not just joking about
something I don't think so he's just
he's just a bit of an asshat who refuses
to remove to move his right arm at all
no he's like a hip-hop guy he's grabbing
his balls
former president Trump
tomorrow I think Cypress Hill family
will have an opportunity to talk about
they're going to a break it looks like
all right Fulton County that street well
really quick what are we about to say
there let's say we can go to another
Trump clip if you want to or if you want
to provide something of commentary there
I I he was basically saying at the
federal level we're going to stop these
smashing grabs I'm like really how
because that's a state issue that you
have to deal with and really it's a city
issue that you have to deal with and you
have to get these stupid Democrats to
have better policies in these cities
where these things are occurring that's
not a federal send in the police thing
because you don't have a police that you
should be sending in I think you're
right but really quickly we should
probably go to since we have a break
here uh some of your content or you were
down there in Milwaukee we're about to
see here first is you spend some time
this is if I'm not mistaken exclusive on
the ground floor Terry Lake and other
candidates yeah catcher for the Brewers
okay let's uh we got the Chris Christie
ad yeah well actually there's a new
campaign ad from Chris Christie that's
right before that if you want to hit
that so it's right before his original
yeah okay let's do that we have a new
Chris Christie yeah that we have the
exclusive here uh at uh later with
Crowder of course you can join Club a
lot of car.com and then Gerald was there
on location in Milwaukee and you can see
the answers that we got from some of
these candidates
Chris Christie
I can't guarantee you success in what
I'm about to do for the Working Man
um you're gonna get some straight talk
from New Jersey
for the truth bag of M M's right Donald
Trump doesn't even have this at games
because the truth matters if you are in
search of the perfect candidate it is
time to leave I am not it we're going to
be small
or are we going to be big
and that's why I came back to tell all
of you that I intend to seek the
Republican nomination for president
United States in 2024 and I want your
support
[Applause]
Chris Christie you make good cookies
[Music]
Kerry lake has decided to join us Gary
thank you very much for being here it's
so good to be back on and and to be in
beautiful Milwaukee wow they've done a
great job with this city absolutely we
were talking about this I believe
earlier in the year and I said look the
best possible scenario is four more
years of Donald Trump and then eight
years of DeSantis at the time because I
thought just stay out of it Donald Trump
is going to go and be become president
again and you thought that the none of
us would be smart enough I thought he
would be right and that would be good
for him and the thing that people liked
about DeSantis he's not been doing any
of that it's almost like he's taking
kind of that Mitt Romney turn that
caused him to change when he was facing
off against Barack Obama and it's like
don't go don't go be who they want you
to be but I I do believe that President
Trump will be victorious at this debate
even though he's not even there I don't
know that there's any point in him
coming to some of these debates I don't
think that people are going to suspend
their campaigns because they are banking
on President Trump either running out of
money running out of support or just not
wanting to deal with it I don't think
any of those things are going to happen
so good luck with that well he's never
going to run out of support the the
people who love president Trump love him
and they will vote for him no matter
where he is they could try to lock him
up they'll still vote for him absolutely
and I will tell you he's already won the
debate I have been doing interviews for
the last couple weeks about the debate
and not once has anybody asked me about
the other candidates it's all questions
about Trump you wake up you turn the
news on it's about Trump and how
brilliant for him to
do an interview with Tucker Carlson the
two people that fox hates the most right
now are President Trump and Tucker
Carlson and tomorrow when fox wants
everybody talking about the little
league game they're going to hold in
here
tomorrow everyone's going to be talking
about Trump and Tucker and Tucker who
can be a tough interview I don't think
he's going to do a snowball or you know
softball no he's been critical of
President Trump before so but president
Trump will be able to get out his ideas
for turning this country around and how
he sees us saving ourselves on the world
stage because we are Marching toward
World War III that is the backdrop of
what's Happening by the way and they
want us to distract it with all these
other things meanwhile the the world is
has been destabilized and we're heading
toward World War III and uh hopefully
they talk about some of these issues
because I think we're going to find out
there's a lot of war mongers in there
one of the main reasons they want to
bring Trump down is he is a truth teller
and a peacemaker he didn't start any
wars and that makes the military
industrial complex which has a lot of
control in this world that makes them
very upset very upset and U.S Rich
there's no money in peace but there's
trillions to be made in war and
president Trump is about peace
absolutely well really quickly final
question can you fast forward a little
bit to president Trump winning the
nomination
selecting a vice president who do you
think that could be and where do you see
yourself going next and maybe those two
things are tied together I'm not saying
they are listen I'm not leading the way
well I think that you know in a year or
so when he does choose his vice
president president Trump is very smart
he'll look at where things are and he'll
say I need help with this group with
that group in this state and he will
pick an incredible vice president
whoever he picks I will vote for
enthusiastically in the meantime I'm I'm
seriously giving it a consideration to
jump into the U.S Senate race in Arizona
we have two Democrats running one who
just announced that she's going to act
like an independent even though she's
voted with Joe Biden 93 percent of the
time and we have an opportunity to pick
up a seat and get finally get in America
first
senator in the U.S Senate one who's
actually going to do work for the people
and so I'm considering that I'll be
making a decision in the next couple
months I just wrote a book unafraid it's
a great book if you haven't seen it get
it it's a page Turner I in in typical
fashion I throw a few punches I would
expect nothing less and I have a few
other things I'm working on right now in
my personal life and I'm really giving
that serious consideration because we
have an opportunity to get a great
senator in Arizona who will serve the
people of Arizona in Washington DC I
love it if you end up running I want a
button and let us know let us know what
you're doing we'd love to stay in touch
with you but thank you very much for
making some time with us I appreciate it
thank you so much and thank you to the
audience out there
foreign
[Music]
bring it up there in the lower quadrant
uh toolman and Nick depalo was with me
his show was on mug club.com mug Club
yeah you get 10 off with the promo code
Crowder GOP debate hey what do you get
you get Nick to pile you get Alex Jones
you get the Hodge ones coming soon you
get Brian Callan you get guns and gear
you get uh our Friday show you get
double the show every single day you get
the investigative unit it does not exist
without your support at mug Club no
corporate donors uh like these pack
puppets
is going to be also Rob's comedy
Playhouse I'm sorry what a terrible name
but it's a very very good venue
September 16th nickdip.com they have
their hands up like they're
kindergarteners the 15th I'm sorry Nick
it has nothing to do with the Sicilian
don't worry it's gonna be packed no
matter what you say Steve I don't think
it's 11 rooms change the truth
uh
cholesterol
[Laughter]
let's just speak the truth okay
president Trump I believe was the best
president of the 21st century
moment I'm not finishing my drink though
but you guys bring up the drinking game
rules so everyone can see them yeah
that's just a drink that's just a drink
I can't finish my drink it was just
filled you understand how much good he
just did Trump is mentioned January 28th
36 all right okay
[Applause]
they could just change the channel to
MSNBC right now but I'm not whatever
president of MSNBC I am running for
president of the United States point
that dark brown fingers
police force Chris Christie you are a
very very bad man
you tell me to go to debate on Fox but
nobody comes do you see people where are
people there are no people
what did he just say this fat book that
he's not paying for his Buffet you sit
here in an answer
you sit everywhere
no don't bail him out Martha you let him
walk let him deal with those booze let
it reverberate into his sister
they're done man fox has hurt himself
yeah moderate moderator interrupted here
you want to stand up for the rule of law
yes and Law and Order
and the fact is that it can't be
selective in your book you had much
different things to say about Donald
Trump than you're saying here tonight oh
it is very true it's very true I read it
and I know
yeah I you know what I quoted Dom
DeLuise look at he's not taking any
better than you two you've never done it
like you've never done anything to try
to advance
except to put yourself forward as a
candidate tonight and here's the thing
we've stood up for long he's in his 30s
Chris you didn't stand up to a waiting
period and people got killed in your
state you stand up to no one Chris
Christie if nothing else tonight please
let his giant bubble be burst as far as
the tough talking straight from the hip
everything about that man is phony I saw
him stand up to the managers at Arby's
you said you have the beef
waikou
advertise that now
he's gonna hang himself right here watch
well you need him yeah
it's got to be cable political pressure
[Laughter]
former Vice President is on this stage
tonight he has faced hecklers on the
campaign Trail over his actions look at
this wooden puppet January 6th today the
vice president
with the certification of the election
I think Geppetto had a weekend with
Pinocchio and Mike Pence happened oh God
did the right thing on Temptation Island
do you believe he did the right thing
absolutely he did the right thing number
one oh you've sucked him
we should be asking ourselves a bigger
question about the weaponization of the
Department of Justice when I'm president
the first thing that's a good thing good
Garland defund the FBI just whoever here
tonight says disband the FBR
intelligence agencies and build Anew is
the guy who should win this debate I've
said that's a close-handed issue for me
you cannot save this country without
disbanding our intelligence agencies who
are political propaganda and hit artist
Wings yes
Mike Pence did the right thing and then
say go after them
against political opponents but all but
all against parents who show up at
school board meetings they're called out
of this deal that's clever that's how
Glenn young won his election that's
right he talked about the critical race
theory he talked about the white
privilege he talked about the
transgender bathrooms and people always
say those social issues don't work guess
what they won junkan a governorship in a
very very blue state so this is some
people say this is ill-advised don't
listen to those people those people are
morons to his homes with guns drawn
because this doj uses their power uses
their Authority not just against
political opponents but against
conservatives and conservative causes it
is time for a change in America
he did go a little bit and I will bring
oh my Pence did the right thing on
January 2nd we need January 6th
weaponization of these federal agents
disband them come on someone grow some
balls here disband the FBI comment I'd
love to see your chat and mug Club but
let's put on a poll do you think we need
you just you're you right now millions
of people out there whether you're
following me with hundreds of thousands
who are watching right now across all of
our platforms you are a sample group
would do you want your candidate the
Republican candidate to run on the
platform of disbanding our intelligence
agencies they want they want you to
think that you're an extremist I think
it's most of you let's put out a poll in
Iraq that you focus on the mission above
all else you can't get distracted so
Republicans we've got to look forward
and we've got to make sure that we're
bringing the message that can win in
November
[Applause]
[Music]
and defend the Constitution of the
United States I think I I think the
American people deserve to know whether
everyone on this stage
agrees that I kept my oath to the
Constitution that day there's no more
important
answer and here's the thing it's not
about just defending
the Constitution yes right exactly you
are no longer a nation or or a candidate
defending the Constitution what you are
doing is trying to undo a president and
by the way you're really talking about
12 years eight years of Obama and four
of of Biden then there were four in
between three really of someone wiping
their ass with the Constitution you're
not defending something anymore you're
trying you're you're trying to
reinstitutionalize the Constitution you
are trying to ensure that you
reinvigorate the American people to
understand you have an entire generation
of people who do not understand or if
they do they don't care about the
Constitution you are no longer in
defense mode you need to be in attack
mode you need to be in rebuild mode and
that's why Mike Pence should absolutely
he should disappear Into Obscurity he's
not talking to the American public and
certainly not the voting base as far as
where they are at this period in time
this is when you wonder about the donor
class
ask yourself about Mike Pence if Tucker
Carlson didn't do what he did with Mike
Pence guess what he would still be a
darling to a lot of the conservative
donor media class and I say this as a as
a you can go back to 2008 on YouTube no
one has a track record longer than me of
being a conservative pretty much basic
pumpkin spice conservative across
the board
but the messaging now is different when
you were at a point in this country it
is a turning point and people like Mike
Pence are out to lunch
consistent with RNC rules Chad's hitting
us up they're saying disband like crazy
yeah let's put on a poll on Twitter yeah
Martha can I answer the question no I'd
like to answer you
vice president all right that's a tough
moment hey hang on
Mike Pence stood for the Constitution
and he deserves not grudging credit he
deserves our thanks As Americans for
putting his oath of office and the
Constitution of the United States before
personal political and unfair pressure
and the argument that we need to have in
this party before we can move on to the
issues that Ron talked about is we have
to dispense with the person who said
that we need to suspend there you go the
Constitution put forward attack Donald
Trump I don't think you're gonna like
how this goes Hot Shot I give him credit
but I mean
he's an idiot yeah I mean I don't know
where what do you think he's going to
gain from saying that you look at the
polls trumps what he has advisors he
should be a Romney type yeah the right
thing and I do think that we need to
give him credit for that but what I will
also tell you is look I mean nobody
needs are some lifts in his shoes two
whether president Trump should serve or
not I trust the American people let them
vote let them decide the American people
don't trust their vote it's a
significant portion of Americans
including by the way Democrats who don't
believe that their vote is secure or
that it's counted properly they're
speaking to people who aren't there this
is the problem with the donor class this
is where Vivek is going to pick up
something the GOP pup do you want a
puppet candidate saying the American
people have to trust their vote they
already don't talk to those people
they're tuning in right now they're
looking for a reason to give you their
vote are you man enough or woman enough
Mickey Haley to take it you have the
balls
but I would say you started off the top
of this hour saying we're going to talk
about China Ukraine education I love the
crime in Transylvania by 40 percent
jukebox impaling's we're up 75 but
Groucho wants his eyebrows back
the garlic Harvest is great
just the suits
and now indeed we are moving on Netflix
if the U.S has committed nearly 77 I
speak on this issue
that on day one you would pardon Donald
Trump I'm the only candidate there we go
let's see what they say listen now we
move our nation forward I don't know and
turn the page forward that's exactly
right we'll be convicted of these crimes
you can make me able to make a
commitment the same justice system that
was this what's the difference between
you and me yeah
I've actually given pardons Governor
state of Indiana it usually follows a
finding of guilt and Contrition by the
individual that's been convicted so will
it if I'm president of the United States
we'll give Fair consideration any pardon
requests but if I'm mad
that's political talk yeah you suck you
know it's not about looking back it was
our man on the ground
it's about January 20th 2017. by the way
drink I put my left hand on January 31st
my first my right hand and I took an
oath thank you
the support and defend the Constitution
of the United States oh boy and it ended
with a prayer so help me God
it was a promise that I made to the
American people more like a statement
but I also made it it's not really a
prayer you made it to my heavenly father
kind of a demand to the Lord four years
I sought to keep that oath
and everyone on this stage needs to make
it clear whether or not they'll do the
same as you're building this job and the
confidence of the American people a vice
president all at all look I've made it
clear I had he's a girl that the
issues surrounding the 2020 election and
the controversy let me tell you about
Men's Warehouse did not come to this had
not come to criminal proceedings
I would rather they have been resolved
by the American people
and the American people alone but no
one's above the law
and president Trump is entitled to the
presumption of innocence that every
American is entitled to bring back up
the drinking game rules really quickly
for people who aren't familiar we're
playing right now and people just please
don't get alcohol poisoning just pick a
light beer anytime Trump has mentioned
January uh 6th or 2020 moderator
interrupts a candidate any Thug Life
moment and you finish your drink anytime
a candidate mentions a Democrat other
than Biden exercises are taken we'll
also add anti Thug Life moment meaning a
low light which is pretty much every
time Mike Pence Martha has a wardrobe
malfunction
in the election
this will have no right that'll be the
halftime show the election
2024. thank you vice president oh yes
that's a little presumptuous if the guy
is you he said leave it to the American
people that's what they were doing on
January 6th
regardless of that the specific
specifics of that plan is there anyone
on stage who would not support any time
in on this the increase of more funding
to Ukraine depends
Europe needs to step up I mean Hey Hey
Ron it's a raise your hand question can
I ask you why they have Dallas Cowboy
logos because they're Americans well
because McCallum was a cheerleader he's
a good answer
not doing it not
[Applause]
you would not support an increase of
funding to Ukraine I would not and I
think that this is disastrous
good point that finger somebody else's
border when we should predictions to
prevent across the invasion of our own
Southern border here in the United
States boom drink what did I say at the
beginning of this bring in Immigration
that was a winning issue for Donald
Trump it's still a winning issue by the
way for that base who voted for Donald
Trump people in the Rust Belt and people
in the states will experience that with
a Southern border it's the one area
where you can pick up some some of the
left pieces of Donald Trump people say
you know what he didn't really deliver
on his promise I will finish with Donald
Trump I think people in New York and
Chicago and Martha's Vineyard are
starting to they might have strong
opinions about that because uh we
shipped them to you four for five with
three triples and a home run I don't
understand the sports reference but I
understand
[Laughter]
was doing to the free Ukrainian people
and let me tell you I want you all to
look around this Arena tonight and
imagine that every one of these
more children outside to make over 20
000 who have been I hate them and I hate
everything he stands for buddy
yeah no no I hate what he says I don't
agree with anything out of your mind let
me just say that just say this Chris
Christie decided he wanted to go over
and see President zielinski right I
don't worry just put him anywhere we
have a new we have a new intern he's
doing a good job
it's the good Tourette's though the
funny kind careful you might appear in
media I got a little Garrick bringing up
for Refreshments to take him to the
Yankees game you'll be your best friend
I had to serve beers beers
right now is lying through his teeth he
didn't go over there to see what was
happening firsthand on the ground we
have meteors Christy you understand
what's going on by hearing look I get it
maybe you think that there's a little
bit more to the story you went over
there because you have a campaign that
is faltering and your only path to
Victory is to stay relevant somehow by
the way he went to read lyrics to John
Bon Jovi to put next to the freaking
Oscar that Sean Penn left over there
that's not going to help them win a war
don't lie and use something that is
absolutely tragic to get your campaign
off the ground do you know why else do
you know what the other reason why he
went to Ukraine because he had to go
there because he endorsed the government
Barack Obama by the way who installed a
puppet government in Ukraine just to be
clear not saying that Russia is Right
Putin dick okay I understand it but
let's not act as though Ukraine is a
Bastion of freedom and democracy let's
go back oh look he's look he's making
he's making the the quintessential
Indian face which I don't even care good
for him
and the Russians back out into Russia
I have a news flash the USSR does not
exist anymore it fell back in 1990.
that's very similar to Barack Obama
though with Mitt Romney where he said
now the Cold War called they want the
policy back has been saying he wants to
re-establish the old Soviet sphere
vice president am I am I imagining this
or is Mike Pence defending funding
Ukraine in a proxy war yes to the
Republic does he think that's what the
Republican voters want right now is that
what you want your comment by the way
hit like if you think that that's a
horrible attack to take it's what the
neocons yep communist China and we are
driving Russia further into China's arms
the russia-china military Alliance and
the very single greatest threat we Face
nobody in either political party's
talking about everybody
moderators interrupting drinks
we're far too good at these drinking
games we have to scale it back Ukraine
will never be in NATO and then somehow
Mr Vice President China will not think
about taking Taiwan
peace through strength which is arming
Taiwan okay here we go am I right yes
everyone in the Republican Party
believes that Taiwan should be armed
should be protected that some of that
makes sense Ukraine Russia it's I'm
sorry it's not our fight in Ukraine you
want to be in NATO guess what you have a
bunch of back payments yep it's Mr
ramaswamy you were mentioned you get 30
seconds so the reality is that today
today what Ukraine
[Applause]
the same people who took us into the
Vietnam War you cannot end it you're not
start another no-win war and I do not
want to get to the point where we're
sending our military resources abroad
when we could be better using them here
at home to protect our own borders
protect the Homeland all right all right
so what I'll do someone play the theme
from home every time he appears in
Russia do not have a military Alliance
that's a very unlikely Alliance to have
right now they have sometimes an
economic China and Russia yeah right
they don't have a military I think he
said that either misspoke or he says
that often maybe he's assuming that will
happen
they have a vested interest in each
other talking about it it's like a
friendship agreement
friendship that's right here there's a
little Mortal Kombat
why first of all the American president
needs to have moral Clarity they need to
know the difference between right and
wrong they need to know the difference
between good and evil when you look at
the situation with Russia and Ukraine
here you have a pro-american country
that was invaded by a thug so when you
want to talk about what has been given
to Ukraine less than three and a half a
pro-american country you mean the only
other country in that sector in the
world that hosts drag shows if you look
at the percentages per GDP 11 of the
European countries have given more than
the U.S but what's really important is
going back to when China and Russia held
hands shook hands before the Olympics
and name themselves unlimited Partners a
win for Russia is a win for China we
have to know that Ukraine Nikki the guys
need a sandwich
look here's what people don't want to
say they want to say ah pro-america and
international relations and of course
this is internet okay are you willing to
go to war yeah by the way 135 billion
dollars this is the only time in history
where you can spend more than many
countries GDP in assisting a war and
claim that you are not in a war right
just to be clear the World Views it as
the United States being engaged in this
war you may not like it you may not
agree with that but that is true and I
understand the arguments regarding
Ukraine and Russia I understand it but
when you actually look at the amount of
money spent I understand that's a drop
in the bucket compared to the inflation
reduction act I get that
but again it is the principle of do we
want to be the country who is involved
in proxy wars with countries who by the
way couldn't she just said pro-american
that's not true about Ukraine certainly
not true about zelinski that is complete
and total horseshit that's neocon
talking points let's go back
he just called her a fake Indian
let me address that I'm glad you brought
that up
of course the catches grab our hands
swatted yourself
don't let her overtalk you and you know
what she will
[Applause]
so our relationship with Israel will
never be stronger than by the end of my
first term but it's not a client
relationship it is a friendship and you
know what friends do friends help each
other stand on their own two feet so I
will lead Abraham Accords 2.0 I will
partner with Israel to make sure Iran
never is nuclear-armed but you know what
I love about Israel and I've been there
probably in the last 10 years more than
most people on this stage you know what
I love about them I love their border
policies I love their toughness
he is bringing it to immigration which
was the singular winning issue for
Donald Trump in 2016. got away from it a
little bit he knows what he's doing
your first obligation protect the
American people in our country and its
people yes and that means you're sending
all this money but you're not doing what
we need to do to secure our own border
we have tens of thousands of people who
are being killed because I know
look I'm gonna go buy wrote
here and please bring it up I think you
probably have this and the change build
a wall change my mind I think the most
generous estimate if I'm not mistaken
for the wall being built as Donald Trump
originally proposed it would have been
about 20 billion dollars I think some
people tried to say it was 40 billion
but the average somewhere was around 20
billion dollars and illegal immigrants
cost the American taxpayer an average of
116 billion dollars a year so if you're
talking about let's call it 40 billion
in let's use the salon sources as
Governor Christian gnome uh sorry uh
Nikki Haley want to use themselves are
using these talking points today from
the far left okay 116 billion dollars is
what's cost to the American public okay
the American taxpayer every single year
40 billion dollars compare that to the
amount of money pledged to Ukraine
that's what it would cost to secure the
Border physically of course we need
better policies as well like deportation
no more dream or act no more amnesty we
need all those things in conjunction but
the point is it is a drop in the bucket
when you're talking about securing the
American people so when people say this
is a very small number and compared to
in comparison to our deficit to our
spending but it's a very large number
135 billion dollars dedicated to the UK
to Ukraine in comparison to what it
would cost to at least secure our border
that's why Republican voters don't like
these people just to be clear secure our
borders first and then maybe you can
make a case to be a neocon foreign
policy Hawk and not with the wall or the
military All the Above serious yeah he
wants turrets it's like Congo for him I
want landmines they work beautiful I
wanted booby draft like Kevin
McAllister's uncle's New York apartment
I'm serious though when they bring up a
wall I laugh even when Trump brings it
up really but we need the strongest
military on Earth but we need a wall
first why then you put people on the
wall if you have to oh this is yours
okay put a fence up three feet up
research it's the guns and Flame throws
that keep people out not the goddamn
wall the most liberal estimates uh
values hit 21 billion 21 billion dollars
yeah 21 billion dollars 116 billion
dollars cost yeah but Trump wants to
z-brick it so it's going to go up they
like they like carrying me over to
Ukraine to prolong a war yes to prolong
a war while the American public is
struggling Haley what's Dracula talking
about
put 87 000 people in the IRS as opposed
to giving the money in this fort we need
to our own border patrol okay well done
Mr Brigham thank you for letting me talk
again guys thank you Lugosi thanks for
reminding the people I'm here yes 87 000
my foot hurts and higher or double the
number of border patrol agents I just
left Yuma Arizona about two weeks by the
way he's going to get fact checked on
that just to be clear and just don't be
fooled by this tomorrow they'll say uh
Tim Scott Miss it's not 85 000 IRS
agents 80 something thousand new IRS
employees are not officially agents who
cares it doesn't matter a bunch of bunch
of pencil pushing sorry potential
pushing pencil-necked with
Glocks it's still a problem
apparently forgot the sunblock listen
security watch list what have been
caught at our border how many have not
been caught at ourselves I think he was
in the it was about 350 to Yuma 350.
for 5 million more we could have the
military-grade technology to surveil our
Southern border to stop thank you
military I don't want to look at them
Crossing illegally are we I want to stop
them what are we doing you have to see
them before you shoot them I want a
laser wall that vaporizes them oh yes
government I want as the super soak is
filled with catfish
what if they have Cuts that's very cheap
I'm saving them money you ever get your
favorite cap oh it would also solve our
our feral cat problem in our inner
cities
right now or Dracula's talking about it
all day we're taking Mass casualties and
those aren't that's a statistic but
these are Sons and Daughters nieces and
nephews that were talking about R Kelly
flying Knight helicopter missions from
San Diego to the Gulf Coast trying to
stop these transnational criminal
organizations they've got better funding
on their side than we've got on our side
yes
Valiant effort seriously for the little
time he gets Mexico vice president Pence
images from earlier this month
it really doesn't help I'm asking a
question earlier
is it just me or does Mike Pence is he
acting like he has this in the bag he
does he's delusional he really is okay
what's Richard Pryor would you and I was
talking about across the board of this
hey there's some
cocaine Shoes by the border patrol law
enforcement as needed
him and lost my goddamn mind man
honestly has to be used for intelligence
gathering purposes this is not what you
know about that whenever I was in the
Bush Administration we went down there
oh that's a ringing endorsement
hey guys you remember when I didn't do a
dang thing to stop the problem because
it's terrible today that's true add the
mustache what's the name of that actor
was the the owner in uh Slap Shot yes
they came out here to see the RNC not
this guy
the toughest candidates in the federal
League oh my God it's perfect
Mexico as a partner we have to use
economic pressure to accomplish that
president oberdor has not been helpful
and we have to use economics
Administration is not using the rule of
law has to matter how we dealt with this
in Arkansas was critical
[Laughter]
here's the thing Special Forces to take
out fentanylabs and people say Ron
DeSantis has answered very clearly on
this question before where he said no I
will not support amnesty whatsoever he's
been very clear about that he just needs
to be clear in this debate not a part of
your Southern border we have to
re-establish the rule of law and we have
to defend our people the president of
the United States has got to use all
available Powers as commander-in-chief
to protect our country and to protect
the people so when they're coming
against the globalists finish the
sentence yes we reserve the right to
operate how many more tens of thousands
are we going to let to die I am sick
I've met Angel moms throughout this
country I met at least in Texas named
Tracy and her son
took one purchase all these angels that
was laced with fentanyl immediately died
that is happening all across this
country because of the poison that they
are bringing in so as president would I
use force would I treat him as foreign
terrorist organizations You're darn
right I would does that mean bombing
them
would have been great if not for the
your darn right I would I'm sorry that's
just not a good way to frame it You're
darn tootin You're darn tootin El Chapo
El Chapo I have a little something for
you and I guess what it's not snack time
right that should have been a thug life
it's an Apache now could it be Satan I'm
not talking Malarkey yes I don't want
any more of your tomfoolery okay this
isn't the local Town Hall hootenanny
you know Jill had some fentanyl in the
kitchen it was awesome he was cooking it
there was a fire that's been eloquently
described here as you guys
again
about who is best prepared to be the
next president of the United States if
you wanted to go to prepare because he
was vice president
of the room is it's like saying I hey I
played I played in the professional
league right and you were dead last and
you scored nothing
Around the Clock I negotiated the
remaining Mexico policy on behalf of the
president
and they allowed us to have people wait
in Mexico while they applied for Asylum
it ended Asylum abuse overnight we got
the Mexicans to deploy their National
Guard to their southern border and uh
Trump did stupid before and I want to
promise you as president of the United
States of America I will engage Mexico
the exact same way and we will partner
with Foss military and we will hunt down
and destroy this guy here's the problem
with Mike Pence he wants to claim credit
for Donald Trump's presidency yeah we
all yeah and then turn on him that's
exactly right pivot when it does by the
way he's like we will hunt down and
destroy the car no you won't the cartel
will always come back you know why
because they have a product and there is
demand it may be somebody else it may
look a little bit different but that is
what history has taught us that means
you don't know what the hell you're
talking about also I have to get cheap
ass fillers in Mexico that's true yeah
Tijuana great for some stuff in a sec
you know man look like Mike Michael
Douglas
[Laughter]
no there's still more we have so many
wonderful people from around the world
who are waiting in line following the
law to try to come here and pursue the
American dream and those people are
waiting and waiting and waiting yeah
because you're in line at Wendy's
[Laughter]
very important as I just said but China
is sending these chemicals to these drug
cartels for them to create the fentanyl
that's a good point hundreds of
thousands of our citizens let's bomb
Chinese are engaging in an act of war
against us
just drop him that'd be a MOAB they
wouldn't be expected exactly
give them 20 minutes in a portal party
and drop that off all that Chris
Christie's will block out of the Sun
we have to fight
we have a lot of these You're Gonna Roll
him at the Mexican card it doesn't look
too bad for a fat guy I hate
that's Millions
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right so really quickly I just want
to go back through a few things that
happened while we were doing that we're
gonna go to a trump uh a trump clip a
trump clip yeah Trump with Tucker
Carlson one of my people that I love to
hate Robert Reich said there's no such
thing as abortion all the way up to the
moment of birth Governor DeSantis is
telling a dangerous lie yeah that is not
true ask Governor Northam that but he
might be too busy doing blackface in his
retirement face glad I had so much so
I'm trying to go to the uh the next
Trump uh clip here gosh it's like 50
pages back up uh you mean president
Donald Trump with uh Tucker Carlson with
Tucker so we are covering and keep this
in the lower third here just so people
can see that they're advertising Birch
gold oh I guess they don't have the uh I
guess they don't have Devane doing it
anymore so look they're really upgraded
they get Pence's nephew yes bill
Pence there there was there were a
couple of them that they gave me they
gave me one really quick uh so I don't
know let's go to the uh um so Gavin news
you can use the hashtag Critter GOP
debate 10 off mug Club at uh creditor
GOP to be it's a promo code use
letterscredit.com we are covering both
the debate as well as the Tucker Carlson
interview that just dropped with Donald
Trump which is this next clip Gerald so
this one is him talking about Gavin
Newsom oh okay good it's another one
they want us to get to but we'll have to
get that okay Gavin Newsom You Gotta
Give me the names if they want them all
right
from Newsome right I mean it could be I
mean you know I always get along well
with him believe it or not but it could
be him could be somebody else he's got a
big
a big load on his shoulders because you
look at California what's happened
you know Paul Pelosi dropped it oh
really the people of the vote for him I
don't even know if they care you know
you look at so many of the things that
are
going on and people don't seem to be in
the old days if you had a bad record it
meant a lot today if you have a bad
record it doesn't really mean anything
yeah well actually you know I don't care
what he has to say about Gavin Newsom
we'll see if he ends up running against
that guy but it's Civil War like it's
actually open conflict that he's talking
about oh I think maybe we have that clip
yeah we have that one great let's hear
this President Donald Trump talking
about about eight seconds uh Civil War
or as Mike Pence refers to it something
he will never touch do you think it's
possible that there's open conflict we
seem to agree towards something I don't
know because I don't know what it you
know I I can say this
uh there's a level of passion that I've
never seen there's a level of hatred
that I've never seen and that's probably
a bad combination
Donald Trump thank you thank you very
much thank you why is he interviewing
him in the slave of Galley
do you see it 12 years Tucker I would
say peacefully go but last time that
didn't work yeah exactly so I don't know
look I don't know I would think there
shouldn't be any type of civil unrest
but if I don't win I can't answer that
question I can't speak for them a lot of
people say if I don't win they might
they might try and take out the
government I hope it doesn't happen I
say no that's the worst thing they say
that's what people tell me there's
nothing I can do
I love his style of pawning it off on
someone else it's just someone else
always I've been talking about that
since 2015. yeah a lot of people tell me
a lot of people like who sang that a lot
of people say that a lot of people you
wouldn't know I know these people
ah he's a great salesman it really is
like here's when people say Donald Trump
is a liar no no look Joe Biden is a
compulsive player Donald Trump's a bit
he's like a car he's a bit of a
artist and that's the exaggerated
there's a big difference it's a huge
difference I mean and and friggin bides
lying about that you know affects
everything Trump might have been
exaggerated about how many people's at
the inauguration right like like Joe
Biden so bidenomics has helped every
single American when they are struggling
more than ever before Donald Trump would
say my wall will be the prettiest wall
like all right it might be okay do you
like zebra prettiest wall my wall would
be like the Bo Derek of well as a
perfect 10. that's what people say I say
maybe it's more like a Kathy Island well
they say it's it's Bo Derek and Tim
all right so we've got the debate coming
back up here but a lot of people are
saying that the Trump interview it
wasn't like it's not Donald Trump being
Donald Trump it's Donald Trump advisors
yeah exactly well you know he's not
punching back at stuff like it's not the
funny when was this recorded do we know
I think a couple of days ago
so yeah that's true for indictments I
mean maybe five you know look that would
get to anybody about 93 charges even Mr
D santis we are back hashtag Crowder GOP
debate and we will see who has the balls
after this to sit down at the rumble
Booth uh on the debate States lock their
kids out of school for a year year and a
half that was wrong we stood up I took a
lot of fire for that I was uh I was
pilloried by the media but I stood for
our kids and as president I'll stand for
you and your kids as well but we have to
make sure
that what our schools are doing is
focusing on solid academics in Florida
we eliminated critical race Theory from
Arkansas
[Applause]
there's no doubt and that's we have
pretty good yeah he's the guy with the
best record and the worst rhetorical
skills I would say that's a thing he's
not great at speaking right now he's not
great at invigorating people but he has
a fantastic record yes yeah he'll he'll
learn that like Pence look at Pence he's
a mess
any foundation in what it means to be an
American
[Applause]
like we said you've said that the
Department of Education the FBI the ATF
the nuclear Regulatory Commission the
IRS the Department of Commerce should
not exist that's correct so good to the
education
so look we have a crisis of achievement
let's shut down the head of the snake
the Department of Education take that 80
billion dollars put it in the hands of
parents across this country this is the
Civil Rights issue of our time allow any
parent to choose where they send their
kids to school every year there we go
school senior should have to pass the
same Civics test that frankly every
immigrant including my mother had to
pass in order to become
this country and the fact of the matter
is the Civics Richard Dreyfus right now
with his new documentary I've been
saying that for years
but you know the word privilege gets
used a lot well you know what I did have
the ultimate privilege of two parents in
the house with a focus on educational
achievement I don't want every kid to
enjoy that it's a part of it we also
have a federal government that pays
single women more not to have a man in
the house than to have a man in the
house contributing to an epidemic of
fatherlessness and I think that's right
but it's a burning hip-hop scene but
don't stop that but that isn't important
point to make because a lot of people
who are labeled when we talk about the
fatherless households in the black
community yeah it's about 50 50 split
half the time it's the moms pushing them
out because they want an additional
check from the government and these men
actually want to support their children
but they can have their wages garnished
they can be put in jail and the mother
has no burden of proof to show that that
money is going to the children so let's
just be clear we talk about fatherless
black households he just made a good
point he's talking about mothers who are
incentivized by the government yes I've
been blaming them for years was that
factual though I'm serious yes wow holy
this issue
completely losing track of the fact that
education differs by States some some
school districts are doing a fantastic
job some lessons but the idea that every
school district State and every teacher
is somehow indoctrining people is just
Falls you know when I was building a
company that's a bad answer it is a
systemic problem systemic racism isn't a
problem systemic educational corruption
is a problem don't bring up the four
exceptions right then we talk to them we
do that and as
governorships
I don't the night before I find out the
students the student finds out I'm going
to go to every class with them I don't
sit in a lecture school districts how to
do it I go and see the experience and
there's a lot of things that have to
change but what needs to change in
education is EV it's Innovation we're
doing it the same way we did it 50 years
ago with Innovation not not regulation I
would get rid of that's not true of
Education that's not true we're not
doing the same way we did it 50 years
ago as a matter of fact we're doing it
worse than before there was a federal
department of education just to be clear
when you hear this by the way gen Z and
a lot of Millennials you go well we do
without a federal department of
education ask your parents the Boomers
who you mock all the time because that's
a cool meme they likely went to school
before there was a federal department of
education and they they actually tested
higher in standardized testing scores
because it was state run and run by
municipality so this idea that you need
a federal department of education no it
has failed and actually the objective
measurements that we have the metrics
shows that it has gotten worse that's
where a guy like what's this I always
forget his last name dug them whatever
lost me
crazy woke things happening in schools
but we've got to get these kids reading
if a child can't read by 30.
eight days after I was born the
Department of Education came around
October 17 1970 years old I am 43 not
yet 44. I agree 100 we blame you yeah
but so Carrie Lake had this right right
so we talked about we did an interview
with Carrie Lake up here she said that
the money should follow the student you
want to change public education you
start incentivizing schools by letting
children and parents obviously parents
make the decision but the children the
dollars follow them they get to pick
where they go if you have a good school
and you're desirable more people by the
way the black and white and the gray
issues coming up it's the one that was
controversial it's the one that went
went on for an hour and a half with of
course a black woman and a daughter who
went to private school from a wealthy
suburban area guess what they attacked
me you'll see this all of them are very
good conversations they went they were
Furious they demanded did I not air it
and after that I said hold on a second
let's see if we can find common ground
in one thing I'm sorry it was it was a
segment that was going to be uploaded as
a video but who's there it was a black
woman and her daughter saying you know
we don't want you to air this we don't
think this is productive and then at the
end of it they agree they said well yeah
school choice a school voucher program
they said how can anyone be against that
I said hold on a second hold on what if
I were to tell you that the only reason
that Democrats oppose it is because they
claim it's racist they said well that's
I said that's my point exactly
that'll be coming out next week or the
week after let's hear Mike can you say
that or did you say what if I offer you
a carton of cools myself
I saw you don't need a president
he said dump it no he didn't say no I
said pop it drop it like it's hot we
need a president who knows he's getting
booed again how the White House Works
what did I miss what are people laughing
at him for he just unbid his fly
against No Child Left Behind when
Republicans were double in the
Department of Education I'll also shut
no get rid of it Department of Education
there's one answer
they put the camera on it's 1988 for
some reason
isn't it school choice to every family
in America so what's up with the boys
regularly hold on
you were in the White House you didn't
get it that's right credit for
everything else and then he wants to
pass the bus we're gonna do this you
didn't do it you know what I'd say I'd
go I go Gerald I was the vice president
okay I went to the funerals
the difference between somebody who's an
automaton and somebody who's actually a
thinking agent in the white house which
we don't have in there today guys so
much
you need somebody of a different
generation to lead this nation yes we do
look at the way
working class majority to deliver a
landslide and I think I'm the only
candidate in this race young or old
black or white to bring all of those
voters along to deliver a Reagan 1980
Revolution is he saying that because
he's between black and white
yeah yeah he's actually darker than Tim
Scott but he's gonna do a side by side I
guarantee I guarantee you oh God no
certainly South Indians not him Tim
Scott maybe not him but South Indians
are darker I'm all for him I like him I
love him I love him I love his food I
love his culture you have 30 seconds on
the same question on Education First of
all look at Arkansas
what does anyone wanted to look at
Arkansas okay exactly what if they look
at Arkansas we've got Walmart otherwise
we wouldn't exist exactly look at all
these trailer parks could you pan could
you pan in this trailer park you saw
that seriously Ozarks to every school in
rural areas offering computer science
yeah the stage presence compete with
China Christian
I really feel like this is a ASA you
ignorant yes yes it's like gosh all
right let me hear this question in this
country you talked about it a little bit
before tonight so is there a role for a
president of the United States in
changing that what would you do to
change that well our nation was found
upon the judeo-christian values that has
made this the greatest nation on God's
green earth I'm a big believer in
Ephesians 3 20 that God is able to do
exceedingly abundance County he was
three-fifths as a person yeah that's
exactly what they're saying Behavior we
want others to follow
on education
the only way we change education in this
nation is to break the backs of the
teachers unions that's violence good
good answer it's too violent that image
keep him into failing schools shoot them
in the head will that work of the
greatest future they could have I had to
soften it I don't know who's President I
don't want them paralyzed some mandatory
military services
military somebody that volunteered to
serve inspired by September 11th and I
deployed to Iraq alongside U.S Navy
that's why I like this guy too
that I think has taught me you know when
you go in that type called monkey pox
anything you mix to follow federalism
assassination attempt tonight I really
thought there was a shot I go Trump's
not even there these guys are in
business
[Laughter]
something completely different she lifts
her shirts
in UFO encounters oh gosh
UFO question and you wonder why Legacy
Media is dying who just said that I get
the UFO question Chris looks like a UFO
I think it was Kristen it was and people
are taking this a lot more seriously and
we're hearing that you know there are
things going on
so we take this about as seriously as
you do Christy would you level well he
likes the flying t-shirts yeah could a
flying sausage get off the planet if
you're in it they bring donuts and
especially coming from a woman from New
Jersey I
it's horrible that Jessica I'm from New
Jersey you asked me about unidentified
flying objects thank you for telling us
what UFO stands for different
um look answer the question of course
the United States is to level with the
American people about everything
the job of the president United States
it's not entirely exactly United States
is to be a role model for our children
yeah
[Music]
low popularity rating because they're
putting themselves before our kids that
what does this have to do with UFOs
nothing he doesn't want to answer that
question
I don't I don't I don't fault him for
this it's a stupid question that's a
really dumb question
is live from the spin room right here
hey that's a casino in Vegas as soon as
they stay who's that guy cmgm Grand
Kennedy is like I'm next
God I like candy okay so uh hey by the
way I should probably tell you this a
little bit and uh I don't know if we
want to take some chats but again the
promo code is Crowder GOP debate you get
ten dollars off hey with mugler what do
you get you get two times a show every
single day with us you get a Friday show
but Alex Jones is Alex Jones 2.0 on
Fridays you get Nick depaolo's show at
Monday through Friday at 5 p.m you're
gonna have Brian Callan show Hodge twin
show you support our investigative
journalism unit and we also have uh some
animated series coming down the pike
none of it happens if not for you notice
there are very very few commercial
breaks in tonight uh which is an
exhausting three hour stream but I do
have to you know every now and then you
know this Nick did you say three we like
to have his contract wow I've been going
a little shot again let's
I thought I heard a shot in the studio
[Music]
I was waiting for Walt the Cronkite come
on Vivek from a Swami was dead at 9 30
Eastern time yes I hate to interrupt
this program
so you know we like to have a little we
like to have a laugh sometimes in the
studio and sometimes we pull some pranks
on each other you know this how long
have we been off and you know uh about
over two hours oh good and uh you know
that Gerald is obviously a very devout
Christian I do because every time I say
something off color he cringes I I know
a little book it's a mix there's an
intersecting it says risen yes by the
way by the way we all agree hit the like
button if you like this eclectic mix
that is going on but we like to have a
laugh I love you Nick and sometimes we
pull some pranks in the office and
because you know Gerald has often talked
about he's talked about really well yeah
you remember so we pulled a little bit
on Gerald this weekend due to the pool
you know I think we all had a we all had
a good time with it what did they do
Gerald what are they Gerald didn't
[Music]
come on guys you got
to color and
what the
guys anybody
hey
what
no way no Steve Steven Steven
Tim no no no no no Tim Tim oh come on
Lord Tim with his PR headband
I did everything I was supposed to do I
went to church I went to Ministry school
I went on missions trips for goodness
sakes you've got to be kidding
Sam oh hey Gerald
perfect
[Music]
he thought he was left behind what an
idiot you got a good sense
left behind
with Sam yeah I mean I know okay there's
a difference I'll take it left behind
with the Antichrist and you know people
dying left and right but not left behind
me please just say that Sam Sam is not
that okay so
let's bring up the drinking game rules
one more time yeah yeah uh they just had
to help touch up Nick because he was
shining like the greasy Sicilian that he
is
take it easy time Donald Trump has
mentioned 2020 January 6th as mentioned
the moderator cuts off or interrupts the
candidates anytime of a thug life moment
and then you finish your drink anytime a
candidate mentions a Democrat other than
Joseph Biden McAllen shows him
been pretty effective so far yeah I'm
feeling it uh do we have the answer
actually on that poll regarding
disbanding the intelligence agency yeah
it was uh I know it was overwhelmingly
yes overwhelmingly disband the FBI I'd
be disappointed if it wasn't an hour
until this is a long commercial break
should we go to uh do we want to go to
really quickly one of uh looks like one
of your schedule your remaining
interviews I know sure yeah yeah okay so
we actually have a poll yeah there's the
poll and it's gotten worse several
thousand votes if you could be worse
than 91 agreeing with you that those
ages is that what it is yeah it's gotten
worse okay so I'm going to go by the way
can I just actually ask a question in
chat why does anyone use that hands like
my hands smell like like my
grandmother's funeral
it's just yes sometimes my wife puts his
on comes in the living room I get
nauseous yeah it really does I'm hyper
sensitive to it but maybe it's just to
have a little therapy session for Nick
but I had a lady sit next to me on a
plane with that yeah and it's like going
into a candle shop for three hours so I
punched her pellets yeah all over my
hands so I don't know how long is this
we have Gerald again bring it up in the
lower third so people can see that Birch
gold is still going on right now there's
a commercial break no I think they're
coming back are they coming no that's
the Reagan Library let's see what we're
Brave so far they're doing this in
September oh they're doing yeah that's
in September uh you sat down with
Marjorie Taylor green or spent a good
time with Margaret and some other
candidates in Milwaukee so uh let's roll
that really quickly as we come back to
the debates uh with people outside of
DeSantis and Vivek who no one cares
about but here's Gerald in Milwaukee
[Music]
so obviously you can see we have
congresswoman Marjorie Taylor green
thank you for hanging out with us for a
minute yeah thanks for having me on
absolutely the Biden crime family name
is
quite a bit I'm hearing a lot of people
talk about that
um you've obviously had a lot to say
about this what do you think is the most
egregious thing that the American people
need to grab a hold of that maybe they
aren't about what's going on well I
serve on the oversight committee and
we've been leading the investigation in
the House of Representatives into the
Biden family and our investigation is
not into Hunter Biden it's into Joe
Biden directly himself the most damning
evidence uh shocking to me was when we
went in the treasury Department I've
been there several times and there's
these reports called suspicious activity
reports SARS right this is a report you
don't you don't have on you there's not
one on me there's not one on most people
watching the show I would doubt hardly
anyone but there's thousands of pages
on Hunter Biden all kinds of Biden
family members but it outlined very
devastating things it showed us that
there were millions and millions of
dollars coming from countries all over
the world going directly into bank
accounts that the hunter Biden and Biden
family members managed under llc's right
I mean you have 20 as well right and
everybody just has 20 llc's that's the
way you normally do business especially
when you're not selling a product right
right working on the inside and really
seeing how
utterly bad it really is I've I've
changed my mindset to the point where
I'm like we only have one choice and it
is to vote if you don't vote you're
really voting for The Other Side not
voting is truly helping the Democrats
yeah congresswoman thank you very much I
appreciate that you're in the fight
continue to do it and we look forward to
seeing what happens tomorrow hopefully
the some people start throwing some heat
we'll see I hope they drop out because
we can just they probably should there's
a number of them we should yes we should
focus our efforts that's not a bad point
I like that
okay thank you very much for being here
it's so good to be back on what's your
take on big Tech I know you've been
mistreated I know we've talked about
that before in the past and that's
that's an understatement I know but tell
me what you think about kind of big Tech
and rumble's place relative to YouTube
to Fox and all those other I'm a huge
fan of Rumble I uh the first time I ever
streamed a video and put a video out I
put I chose to do Rumble rather than
YouTube because YouTube has been behind
censoring Americans on talking about the
most important issues of our time right
what's happening I think the the um if
there are good ratings on this because I
think with missing president Trump I
don't think people really are going to
watch that much but I I predict that
Rumble may have more more viewers than
Fox News absolutely and and so I think
we are seeing the beginning of the end
of old school Legacy Media and we're
seeing it being replaced with Outlets
where we can put the truth out where
people can
um get to it without having to pay a
huge cable bill without having to buy up
a bunch of the stations that they're not
interested in watching on cable news and
frankly
um I think Fox is going to struggle with
their ratings tomorrow yeah I do too
thank you very much for making some time
with us I appreciate it thank you so
much
all right guys thanks for joining us we
ran into somebody all right we're going
to cut into that they're doing closing
statements really quickly so we want to
go to that and we'll see who actually
sits down at the rumble Booth here for
the Crowder GOP debate Tim Scott closing
statements
he's getting laps I'm Tim Scott I'm
asking you for your vote and if you're
entitled I'm asking you to turn up for
me you can go to votetimscott.com for
more information or to make a
contribution
you did a good job
no thank you Brett thank you Martha look
everybody on this I love funnel cake the
next president of the United States and
the only way that's gonna well I spent
three weeks in Iowa I'm the only one on
this stage who's ever beaten the
Democratic incumbent or eating I did it
in a deep blue State being outspent
three to one
beating a democratic incumbent is not
easy the last Democratic incumbent
president who was defeated was Jimmy No
Weight Watchers
as a republican in New Jersey show me
he's not a planet yeah some of you can
defeat your weight and then
he does Fight Hard against waste he he
licks his plate clean yeah
you know there's Governors all over the
world starving you death yes that's one
because of you some other nominee who's
never beaten the democratically I'm the
one who can win this race
[Applause]
my husband Michael a combat veteran from
Afghanistan ah off at 4 a.m for another
year-long deployment
I watched you wouldn't have been happy
30 soldiers pick up their two duffel
bags of belongings to go to a country
they've never been
all in the name of protecting America
yeah not you they are willing to protect
us from there we should be willing to
fight for America here I will beat Joe
Biden and he knows that you're a global
strengthen our economy and we'll bring
this inflation down we want to put
transparency in the classroom we will
secure our borders we will have the
backs of our law enforcement and we will
make sure we have a strong National
Security and once again we will make
sure we have an America that is strong
and proud We have a country to save join
us go to nikkihaley.com and let's get it
done and I'll stop shopping at Marshalls
[Applause]
[Music]
this evening it's an honor to be here
Joe Biden has weakened America at home
in abroad still funny
foreign
the disasters withdrawal from
Afghanistan their war on energy
runaway spending that launched the worst
inflation in 40 years a crisis at our
certain order an assault on our values
and liberties
and the American people have had enough
but I know we can bring it back
but different times called for different
leadership Jesus
sorry Mike it's out of a movie proven
maybe this is
the Trump Pence years you can turn this
country around faster than you can
imagine you couldn't turn on a pickup
truck you didn't because I have faith in
the American people you do a good decent
hard-working faith-filled idealistic
people this country and I have faith
that God is not done with America yet
and if we will renew our faith in one
another and renew our faith in him who
has ever guided this nation since we
arrived on these Wilderness Shores where
has he been the last two years no no no
we don't need to renew our faith in each
other if it includes corrupt members of
the government that is not the people
that is not the American populace who
are speaking to Vivek let's hear him to
celebrate our diversity and our
differences so much that we forgot all
of the ways we are really just the same
as Americans Bound by a common set of
ideals that set this nation into Motion
in 1776 and this is our moment to revive
those common ideals God is real there
are two genders fossil fuels
human Prosperity reverse racism is
racism an open border is not a border
parents determine the education of their
children the nuclear family is the
greatest form of governance known to man
capitalism lifts us up from poverty
there are three branches of government
not four and the U.S Constitution has
the strongest guarantor of freedom in
human history that is what won US the
American Revolution that is what will
win us the revolution of 2024. thanks
for letting me introduce myself and
finally the Mets pretty good
game set match let's see Governor
DeSantis hi guys uh where's the Coke I'm
Ryan DeSantis
I got no strings to hold me down this is
our time for choosing we will send it
back to his basement
here's the decline of this country I'm a
blue-collar kid I work minimum wage jobs
to be able to vote for me it's allowed
for I understand the American dream and
I know how that slipped away from so
many millions of Americans will restore
it I'm a veteran who served in Iraq I
know what it means to put service above
self I'm also a dad and a husband of six
five and three-year-old I understand the
importance of protecting parents rights
and the well-being of our children in
Florida we showed it could be done I
made promises and I delivered on all of
those promises 2024 is make or break
we're not getting a mulligan no excuses
I will get the job done and as your
president I will not let you down God
bless you all
no that was bad I'm sorry
[Applause]
but I had a great time but first I have
to find the last remaining Kinkos
had a great time
um all right so look again the uh promo
code is if you go to lotuscraft.com it's
Crowder GOP debate you get 10 off if you
join up now none of this happens without
you uh we're going to see right now we
have someone on the ground there in
Milwaukee to see who's going to sit down
at our booth we have a rumble has a
booth going on there if you're watching
on YouTube head on over to rumble we're
going to go to Mud Club exclusive after
I don't know the timeline here tonight
because we're waiting to see the
candidates who sit down I do know we're
going to see what we can get it's
basically the wild west out there after
this what's the wild west and of course
they have some stops they have to make
first with people who've actively either
contributed to their campaign or
provided press as you know pro bono but
anyone who wants to sit down and look
what questions would you have for these
candidates send them in uh I think
obviously it seems like tonight Vivek
was the biggest winner and I understand
that people will say well hold on a
second is rhetoric doesn't maybe
necessarily match uh his own rhetoric in
the past and I I don't really I've
looked I've spent a lot of time looking
into Vivek I don't really see the the
waffling that people claim I think that
he's provided Clarity on some answers
you have to understand this is not a
management public Spotlight a whole lot
this is not a man who's been in public
office and so what you know about his
points of view in the past either coming
from excerpts of his book or really
interviews where he's not consistently
in front of the press I think tonight he
made it pretty clear where he stands I
think it was kind of coming out party to
the American public I think he did well
I think that DeSantis did all right and
surprisingly I keep I never get the
guy's name right what's his name the
governor burgum stop it I would rank him
number three after those two
surprisingly interesting than some of
the other people oh yeah his looks yes
um
yeah but as far as Vivek and he's saying
you know people pointing out some things
he said maybe he's evolved on the issues
yeah like the Democrats say yes exactly
when they flip flop a little bit but
I've evolved on this so but in their
case he did what I thought yeah he did
I've been saying it on my show uh for a
few months now because every time I've
seen this guy whether it was on Fox a
year and a half ago tweet I go damn what
is he impresses me every he has a he has
a different take on these things that
everybody else does he's very eloquent
and to me maybe I'm just uh you know sad
but he seems more sincere I don't know
no I think you're right I think
self-made millionaire which is the
closest example I could point to would
be Carly fiorina in 2016. no why do you
do that and so I hope that he doesn't
have he doesn't make the same mistake
where Carly fiorina that came in as a
contender and then all of a sudden have
the Mitt Romney advisors in her ear but
she was a failure as a CEO remember well
that's one thing actually I will say in
her defense people don't realize that HP
was hemorrhaging hundreds of millions
and then they started hemorrhaging far
less so if you're going into a company
like okay they're losing 800 million one
year the next year they lose 200. I
bought a printer from that and it
didn't work for two weeks
but that's the closest comparison
honestly that I would have and I just
hope that he doesn't make the same
mistake uh do we think that anyone here
closed the gap on Donald Trump I think
that Vivek maybe closed the Gap as far
as being a Top Choice for VP for Donald
Trump he uh he already I know it's early
to say this he's going to be in a
cabinet yeah he's gonna be in a cabinet
position I think it'll eat a lot of
closet I said a cabinet yeah I know that
would be uh bergam
coffin yeah exactly well the evening
and I don't again we're kind of in a box
here just so you know we're in a studio
where we don't have anything other than
the air support that's provided to us
for Mission Control we've been doing a
very good job tonight I would be willing
to bet willing to bet that people on
Twitter on social media are outraged let
me guess over Vivek saying that climate
man-made climate change was a hoax
over the idea of defunding the Federal
Department of Education I'm just going
on what they think are going to be their
winning issues and of course they'll go
in on Pence on the federal abortion ban
but they're talking about lefties yeah
I'm talking about lefties I'm willing to
bet that's what's going on on Twitter
right now on the internet folks they're
going to try and go after Vivek for
saying that he would uh you know that
man-made climate change is a hoax so I
think what we're seeing right now is
that the Vegas oddsmakers are saying
that DeSantis did better than Vivek
right
down just a little bit I don't think so
so here's what I hear here's what I
heard from Vivek that I didn't hear from
anybody else a very clear concise what
six seven points that he gave at the end
there every single time he came back to
this he went head on into these issues
the other guys gave very canned
responses that's I think the scientist
did give some pretty clear answers and I
do think that he had the strength of
being able to point to his record as
Governor he does so I again I think he's
a guy whose record his rhetoric doesn't
match up with the strength of his record
and I like to send us a lot right so put
him you put good you want actions not
talk right exactly but you put him next
to Vivek right and you go hmm DeSantis
all of a sudden seems very kind of like
stodgy and kind of tight and he doesn't
really put him next to Donald Trump now
in your mind yes and that's what I was
thinking he will look like Mike Pence
before you know it if he doesn't change
yeah what he's doing DeSantis tonight
would not fare well against Donald Trump
in a debate Vivek probably would if he
didn't have to balance kind of trying to
court the pro-trump audience but I do
think that the scientists really would
have a tough time uh going up directly
against Donald Trump yeah and so
according to our website poll actually
this just in from brought again 74 of
you think that Vivek ramaswami won
[Laughter]
yeah I I feel like Tim Scott kind of
hangs around a little bit
guys he's playing he's articulate he
just he doesn't like
no I I think I I mean I'm not surprised
by ASA Hutchinson like he just seemed
like he was a fish out of water one of
the first to go I think he was pulling
at point eight percent
yes politics like by the way it should
be noted that there's a plus minus
he would have done better
remotely and so then bergram just he was
he was a novelty because I didn't know
that uh the vampires were right
talking about it right let's go to CNN
right now and see if they're making the
attacks that I thought they probably
would to know the difference between
evil when you look at the situation with
Russia and Ukraine here you have a
pro-american country that was invaded by
a thug so when you want to talk about
what has been given to Ukraine less than
three and a half percent of our defense
budget has been given to Ukraine if you
look at the percentages per GDP 11 of
the European countries have given more
than the U.S you crazy
that's the first time they've ever given
anything right
this is two I know but what I'm saying
is they haven't paid into NATO so of
course they have the money for Ukraine
they have a little money they have the
money for virtue signaling yeah and
they're right next door
because you have the backs of your
friends Ukraine it's a front line of
defense our friends Ukraine is not our
friend just to be clear neither is
Russia but Ukraine is not our friend
right and the baltics are next that's a
World War we're trying to prevent more
look at what Putin did today he killed
Pagosa maybe yeah by the way I was going
to say that was a pretty bold claim to
make out there emphatically that uh
Putin killed uh Pagosa because of the
the plane crash no that was definitely a
faulty uh Muffler yeah it happens all
the time he also he also went down with
the brother Scott Brown so it's really
strange
[Music]
what happened what did he say uh
I didn't hear it either I think he said
something about like you'll enjoy uh
your new position on Race yes I heard I
heard some Warhawk she's like the bow
we've got the potential for that but
okay let's hear what uh Anderson with
Bill Kristoff
Mantra is I don't back down to bullies
and she had to show that because she's a
strong woman
come back so tired of that frankly talk
louder than him
um which you know and sometimes as a
woman oh Jesus
as a woman Nick shut up she said as a
woman yeah she's so oppressed about the
policy here that is really an issue I'll
take it a Red Lobster on Thursday
support
she raised about uh kind of pulling back
from support for Israel is not popular
among Republican voters and sometimes it
seems like he puts those things on the
table just to say well I'm gonna throw
out the idea that no one's going to talk
about but on the debate stage that's
when you get called out for things like
that Trump did this in 16. yeah I mean
we went we watched him
throw out things that were not party
Orthodoxy and we all said I tie my tie
like an ascot but it what we learned
later was it wasn't about uh the policy
as much as it was about the attention
you know well I mean what were your
talking points in and be as boring as
possible tonight in the post debate
analysis like were those handed out
Stephen yes great question Nikki Haley
is arguing Ronald Reagan's position why
are we focusing on Nikki Haley on Cena
of course because she's a woman
not the winning position with the base
of the party right now when I was out in
Iowa I was struck by so much you hear on
the other side not so much about Putin
it's not about ideology it's not even
about America's leadership in the world
it's that they feel that they are
getting screwed by Washington and yet
Washington keeps sending money to other
places not them good point that's more
what it's about it's like we have been
ignored and we keep sending our money in
other places yeah so she's trying to
she's traveling trying to have an
American leadership in the world against
the Communists against the murder
against a thug on the fact she's right
but it rings Hollow with a lot of
Republican voters who just think you're
another politician what about my
community absolutely the song that I
that I referenced at the beginning of
this you know please tell us
the first reference to rich men north of
Richmond is going to take place and I
didn't realize that fox was going to
raise it but to the point John's making
uh you know a lot of them by the way we
are going to have Patrick Bet David on
the show some of you may know him as Mr
valuetainment I call him Patrick David
he's going to be on the show in a little
bit what do you think he's going to say
about this debate I bet she's gonna go
okay look
my men my men
let me put it to you this week okay so
tonight right we have a problem we have
the debate okay and then people are
saying okay right look let me put it
that way no maybe okay all right maybe
we want to look at Nikki Haley or maybe
some people are going to say uh she's a
shrill right and well then they
might say hold on a second they might
say okay uh Rama Swami Point his finger
a lot right but does that guy Patrick
Bet David if I'm trying to solve the
problem okay have big biceps right okay
or does Patrick Bet David have the
biggest biceps let me put her to it that
way I'm gonna put it to a poll to the
audience we'll get back to it I'm gonna
go back with the RFK Junior okay yeah uh
I don't know what he's gonna say so look
we do have an interesting question from
by the way before people get he's
probably my favorite podcast
no he's uh he's a Syrian he's Iranian
he's like a multi-millionaire oh very
successful very great guy
um we we had the opportunity to meet him
down in Florida
the most important part of it but we
actually had a question on there do you
think that Vivek and this isn't just a
question from our audience this is
actually a question that was posed
online that we think maybe we should
address a little bit do you think he's
more of like the star of the party right
now
um you know and and he won't really last
he's like my gut says that's probably
the case you think I don't I think well
he's got a lot of substance Stephen why
why do you think that that's your gut
well here's what I think is I think that
he has a lot of so he's he's not it's
like uh Michael Keaton in night shift
he's an idea man okay but for the first
time he's really going to have to defend
them and here's what happens even if
you're better at defense for example he
may be better Remus want me at defending
them than Ron DeSantis or certainly than
Hutchinson right but he's going to have
to defend them to a different degree
than anyone else because he's been a
breakout star so the attacks that are
going to come are not going to be uh
proportional with uh the level of
defense that he's has been forced to
sort of Mount in the last the underdog
yeah he's no longer the underdog and
that really is difficult to navigate
that's why these people they end up
feeling overwhelmed and they end up
hiring the old GOP advisors now he's
painted himself into a good one where he
cannot bring those people in
um I'm not saying he won't I'm just
saying that I think a lot of I've seen
this in the past where people don't sort
of foresee the potential pitfalls that
come with being thrust into a national
Spotlight yeah uh and and I'm hoping I'm
hoping that he rises to the occasion and
he very well could but I could see it
going either way I don't I think he's
well equipped and especially after
watching the Schmucks he's up against I
know and I think he has been having to
defend his positions the last couple of
weeks yeah yeah and and I don't know
darling right now well for a reason
though you know I rarely think he's got
substance
um and the diversity thing doesn't hurt
well I'm serious
no you know what I mean a lot
of fact if we lived in a perfect world
even a normal world the fact that
everybody in this country can't look at
what we've been watching in the white
house for the last three and a half
years yeah and go you know what not only
does Biden suck the Democrat Party
and I gotta believe there's a lot more
people that are feeling that way than we
know I'm hoping maybe I'm having a dream
here no no but not so I think and we
need a young guy like to say so I think
what he brings to the table is a very
Trump quality in that he is a very clear
Communicator he can answer off the cuff
he some of the video footage that we
actually showed earlier can I pause you
just really quickly yeah just so you
know when people are saying oh they
thought the oddsmaker said that the
Santa's one have you noticed that CNN's
Chiron has not switched from ramaswamy
at all since the debate they know that
tells you who they know is most
dangerous to them absolutely the entire
post debate Roundup has been Rama Swami
until they went to change it as soon as
you said it but they just said ah nice
yes but they still have them on the
screen so exactly so sorry go ahead
Gerald but I think that's great Fox News
on their air that's fantastic I love
that for them no I I do think that there
is something to what you're saying
Stephen though that he is no longer kind
of the underdog he's no longer the guy
that just kind of the outsider coming in
all of a sudden all of the attention
will be focused on him DeSantis I think
in some ways likes this because the
other candidates have to punch at Vivek
yes right instead of a little heat off
yeah you're right my theory is this the
people that are voting for Donald Trump
are voting for Donald Trump period
you're not going to change their minds
all of the other votes that are up for
grabs are either going to go to DeSantis
or Vivek or some combination thereof and
maybe somebody else is going to hang
around for a little while DeSantis needs
vivec to be defeated whether it's from
him or everybody else ganging up on him
he doesn't really care because he wants
all of those votes to go to him so that
he'll be the last man standing and
challenging Donald Trump and maybe some
way somehow he can overpower him I don't
see that happening vivex going to stay
around he's got his own money he's got a
ton of support he's got a lot of young
very engaged people which is kind of
hard to do and he's got a ton of free
media if that changes if CNN stops
inviting him on if Fox runs away from
him and goes somewhere else he'll figure
something out he'll figure something out
but it'll get a lot harder really quick
this is Sprint
[Laughter]
the one thing DeSantis has over Vivek is
is like you said great Governor he has
done this stuff he's not just bringing
it up and there's a reason people
fleeing from California New York and
these blue cities we make fun of I agree
so if people will sit there long enough
for you to tell them that he's a great
governor and understand the news yeah he
needs to punch in a little faster
exactly right it doesn't matter what the
truth is it matters what you can people
just people in a short period that's
truly yeah more about Optics and then
yeah but you know he did can his
campaign manager who sucked I don't even
know who it was no that's true though I
tell you what though here's it's really
simple these candidates all need to
understand that this campaign needs to
be all gas and no breaks period that's
right that's it and I don't understand
why they aren't all doing that look of
course Hutchinson is sitting down with
Dana Bash naturally now by the way I'm
sure we could have gotten him to sit
down but we don't want him at the rumble
Booth uh really quickly before we go to
that uh before we have Patrick Bet David
on we'll see the candidates who we have
on here in a little bit I'm hearing now
that we actually do have our on the
ground course Finnegan uh who is there
again in Milwaukee right now who finally
uh tracked down some folks let's go
foreign
you took some chances let's see how it
paid off brother not well Stephen
not well
apparently security is pretty tight so
you got
you have nothing going on well
[Music]
I got this lapel pin of the American
flag and now they took it
in my microphone oh boy
it's it's kind of par for the course for
you isn't it basically
basically
[Music]
well only four more years until that
retainer is not obligatory I know you
know I should have just stayed up there
instead of sending I don't know and Nick
depaolo Nick dip you can go watch him a
mug Club Monday through Thursday 5 p.m
or September 15th go see him at Rob's
comedy Playhouse there we go in Buffalo
New York look two nights after that
hilarities in Cleveland OH are you yes
is it the two nights after that I
thought it was the following weekend
I can't plug it here no no we understand
yeah all right so we have uh do we want
to watch some more of the uh the Tucker
Clips with uh with Donald Trump or is it
just kind of people are saying there's a
little bit of a so much going on the
only the only thing there was there was
a clip about the uh indictments being BS
that maybe had a little humor to them
um so if you want to watch that really
quickly I know we're working on the the
connection with Rumble right now to make
sure we're good to go outside the booth
with uh Patrick okay so if you want to
do that really quick well I do think
this goes back to kind of treatments I
think is the the name our uh predictions
predictaments pretty much spot on yeah
honestly as far as what we expected
tonight actually the surprise for me was
Christy didn't go harder after Trump
I I figured he was just gonna I think he
did it for a moment and saw the audience
reaction yeah that's what I think which
I give him credit for yeah I mean
because I think he's a big push but he
he's stuck it was stuck to his uh you
know eclairs and uh
he put up a good fight but let me ask
this one do you guys
in the back of my head when we're doing
all this stuff yeah maybe I've grown too
cynical
um I feel like I'm participating in a
game I'm sorry the last election really
no not by my hard drive and I just feel
like this is all a big script and a show
we're part of it until the Dems try to
steal another I think that the market
has to be so significant and we do need
to definitely I mean look that's why we
fight back with uh the tools that we
have is you know like for example we
talk about my club but there's a reason
that we tell everyone by the way to head
over from YouTube to rumble because if
you just look at the hunter Biden store
we've talked about this that last
election all of the interference
allegedly wouldn't have made enough of a
difference and so what we can't do is
install Governors who need to do their
job as it uh sort of what it relates to
no no it would have yeah well in other
words all the election interference
wouldn't have been able to save it for
them if people just knew about the
hunter Biden laptop story and the
corruption we know that there would have
been enough votes that would have
switched that they could not that would
have been insurmountable so that's a
multi-pronging approach with the media
and fortunately like we've talked about
tonight we see the candidates who are
GOP donor class puppets and a lot of
people and unfortunately the right wing
media follow suit and so you look at a
lot of the same talking points I expect
you'll see a lot of the candidates
making the rounds on a lot of these
shows issuing the same talking points so
it's a multi-pronged approach we need to
fight back on the big media sphere big
media big Tech right I always call it
the entertainment uh media big Tech
industrial complex then there needs to
be on a state level there needs to be at
least adhering to your state
constitution certainly Governors making
sure things like voter ID and uh and
really sunlight being a disinfectant but
what we can do is certainly fight back
with Independent Media that's the first
step that's the Vanguard and you guys
can support it if you think that we do
enough it uh my club.com you get 10 off
and if not hey then don't support us we
need to do better uh say right wing
media other than Fox who are you talking
about talking about well unfortunately
right-wing media and I've talked about
this quite a bit in the past is uh it's
dominated by a lot of non-profit
influence and so the problem with
non-profit influences that you it means
you have donors and it means that those
donors get to dictate content and a lot
of these for-profit businesses by the
way like the biggest media companies
online that exist in the conservative
sphere also have huge non-profit sectors
and there's a lot of funding of uh the
funds but what do they when you say
dictating content where on what
platforms or what well we don't
necessarily need to name names but I'm
pretty sure people can guess and take
the top five yes yes that's the I can't
guess that's why I mean I mean Nick
quite literally billions of dollars in
non-profit right it's a 501c3 or a 501c4
these are not businesses and so
unfortunately when you are beholden look
that's why we have the investigative
journalism unit the people we have here
going we're thrilled going wait we don't
just have to oust a congressman no no
whatever it is that you think is most
important when you have a donor they
it's this it's okay and I'm gonna give
you 10 min you forgot to say the magic
word and that's when people often wonder
why I conservatives so far behind often
on the cultural fight that's why because
for the left as as ironic because all
this is they largely are propelled by
for-profit Industries with the media
with the entertainment industry with big
Tech that's why there's a CNN and MSNBC
and all that outnumbering and we got Fox
well we don't even have foxes we don't
even have Fox is the only one but then
if you look online right again you're
it's you can't fight back when you have
donors dictating what it is that you can
and cannot say and we see that a lot
unfortunately yeah but that's our media
it's not just the don't it's not just
the political well it's issue it's the
media industry in the right yeah it's
the advertising connection too that's
why you have to decouple from
advertisers as you're modeling yes even
said that he's done a lot of things I
don't agree with since saying that by
hiring the CEO he hired and other things
but that's the thing you have to do
because if companies go that's not safe
that's not a safe thing for us to say we
don't want to advertise there all of a
sudden dollars get pulled out of it yeah
um well to give you an idea just let's
just say one two let alone three of our
Chris Christie Jokes which by the way
we're superb perfect the fat jokes I'm a
child I still think they're funny
there's not a single other conservative
media entity who would have allowed that
not one it wouldn't be allowed and guess
what there are enough people out there
who enjoy having a laugh and enjoy
different kinds of content but that's
the problem with having a donor class
dictating not only the candidates but
the media and we're able to call balls
and Strikes and it also makes it more
challenging why would they think like
that when the average American is like
us and Howling well the average American
isn't the donor yeah Patrick Pitt David
is ready for us to give us a little post
debate all right so look let's go to my
main man okay very excited let me put
your two that way Patrick David Mr David
can you hear me sir can you hear me can
you see me
okay good just need it on there let me
hear you there can you hear me can you
hear me now oh boy we're hitting one
second we're hitting this is a little oh
perfect I can hear you now sir look at
you you're looking 10 but you always
look 10. all right let me ask you Mr
David uh what did you think of the
debates tonight who came out the big
winner um we had our predictions but I I
don't want to lead the witness here I
think I know what you're probably going
to say
yes and by the way I I don't know what
the media is saying so whatever I say to
you is purely fresh out of being in
there watching what happened had a
audience was reacting uh I thought vivec
had a great turnout uh in multiple areas
I think I give him an eight and a half
is what I give him he could have had a
higher score but I think Nikki Haley
when it came down to foreign policy uh
had a bit of an edge now remember guys
this is not about who you like or who we
like and who's your guy and who's that
person's per you know who you're rooting
for I thought Nikki had multiple good
moments and quite frankly a lot of
people in the audience were reacting to
her very much oh come on now she was not
on my list of anybody that was going to
react I thought Tim Scott was a little
bit flat I thought he said the right
things I thought he was likable I
thought he looked like somebody that
would make a good VP I didn't see that
as a person that would be a good number
one I thought Mike Pence was very
aggressive uh that doesn't mean it was
good aggressive but I thought he was
aggressive and he was trying to impose
us himself out there and you kind of
have to see a couple times he had to be
stopped uh who else can DeSantis I
thought he had the scripts very well if
there were six scripts and eight lines
that the scientists had to hit I think
he hit a hundred percent of them and I
was watching very closely when the
breaks would happen yeah who would talk
to who during the breaks the Santos and
Christy would speak a lot and if you
notice DeSantis if we were to count how
many shots he took at Trump I don't know
how many times he took shots at Trump
maybe even zero but you heard Christie
do it so Christy was a mouthpiece to say
the things that maybe the Santas wanted
to say about Trump but he didn't have to
say it so strategically I thought it was
a very good strategy by the way and I
mean I would say frankly I don't have an
opinion on them well Pat yeah no one
does either Bella Lugosi look-alike
bergam but uh I do you're so congenial
by the way and this is why I think you
get all of these guests who come on and
don't realize what it and I mean in this
in a good way like what a sniper you are
and how Surgical you are you just said
like you know I think that if uh he had
six scripts he hit all of them that is a
way to say a little bit in a friendly
way in a respectful way that DeSantis
obviously has to go with talking points
a little more and I do think that's an
interesting Dynamic that only you could
provide Insight uh you know here for the
audience if he was talking a lot with
Christy that does seem like there's a
little bit of a double cross maybe right
I get to be good cop you get to play bad
cop you think that's what was going on a
little bit with DeSantis and Christy
I think we're naive to think uh people
are not doing that I think we're naive
to think I never thinking me and Mike
Pence don't have a partnership going on
where there had a moment to show that
they disagree but it was something they
disagreed on that wasn't really
important but they agreed on the bigger
issues so I saw some kind of a
connection between them two uh but yeah
look I mean it's strategic vivec
obviously if you were to say close your
eyes and say who was Trump was Trump in
the debate tonight you would say
absolutely how through Vivek so these
are strategies that they're playing and
for us to try to just pin it that the
sentence is playing that strategy with
Christy it's naive everyone's playing it
yeah I think it's a that's a very good
point and it actually provides some
insight that we couldn't have I think
Gerald has a question for you I was
actually going to piggyback off of that
so it looked like Christy went after
vivec a little bit more than I expected
I figured that Christy was going to go
after Trump but vivec is the real
problem for DeSantis in my opinion if he
stays around he steals vote it's from
DeSantis the people would go to him is
that is that what you're saying do you
think that that was actually that the
target was not just Trump but vivec with
Christy
if you notice there was a part where
Mike Pence took a shot at vivec about
the script hey Slow Down slow down like
trying to say you're a fast-talking
salesperson you know and then you know
Pence had a line that got a reaction he
says look we need to kind of not not a
vote for someone that's going to be too
old or Too Young obviously they're too
old he's talking Biden and uh Trump and
Too Young he's talking about Vivek but I
think America's maybe at a point where
you know they don't want a pence and you
know Vivek flat out called everybody
these are you know Super PAC puppets
those comments that he made and I mean
he he did not hold back so I I wouldn't
be surprised if Pence was not happy with
vivec but I thought vivec
did exactly what those who are pro-trump
would have wanted him to do so again
even though Trump wasn't there he was
that's exactly right that's exactly when
it was happening you know we were
watching this live and streaming it and
I said you know if you were just to
change if you were to say uh if you were
to read this from a script what Vivek
just said and say Donald Trump said this
you would read it and go and do you what
do you what a Super PAC puppet that's
the choice I'm gonna that is quite a
quite literally exactly something and I
wonder if he's positioning himself do
you think with someone like vivec who
maybe doesn't have a ton of experience
we've often asked who would be the VP
candidate for Trump obviously Carrie
Lake would be up there it seems like a
lot of people aren't necessarily willing
to take the risk you think vivec is more
likely to be sort of tapped for that VP
spot or certainly a cabinet spot after
tonight then uh maybe going for the
presidency
I have a I have a very hard time with
that because when you have an alpha
personality like Trump you cannot have
an alpha as a as a VP you just can't
it's just not going to work out when
you're running a company typically if
the CEO's Alpha the number two has to be
a little bit of a guy that knows how to
privately call you out but publicly hold
you up and and I don't know if Vivek as
a Founder CEO driver who's built
multi-billionaire companies in his mind
he probably sees himself as an equal to
Trump because he thinks he did it on his
own so even on the inside vivek's a
pretty confident guy here's a guy that
came from a mom and dad that came here
two years before he was born so yeah I
don't know I don't know if I see him as
a VP I think there's a good types of
people that Trump would want as a VP if
you want to look at everybody on that
stage it 100 loyalty is important to him
we were just with Carrie a few minutes
ago Kerry somewhere around here number
one is loyalty carries Super loyal he
values that a lot and number two it's
somebody that's not going to outshine
him and I think Tim Scott is a as a
great candidate as a VP because he's
just not going to outshine him yeah I
would hope that's not the case and you
know you have the most the best person
for the job but I do understand that
those Dynamics need to be taken into
play were you about to ask him I'm just
gonna say this is Nick Nick de Paulo
hero I just learned so much from I I
really didn't know about those games
yeah them speaking you know uh DeSantis
and Crystal oh Patrick Patrick what
David is a killer yeah
that I never heard I I see but I was
thinking of Avec
um was playing it look I know I'm not
going to be the president I I see him
playing as maybe Chief of Staff or
something like that and and Trump's
going to be if Trump's around is going
to be done in four years yeah I see him
taking a prominent role there but again
he makes a great he makes a good point
because think about all those people on
stage Mike Pence was the guy who Trump
shows as his VP last
in his administration would he be afraid
of him I know he's loyal to a fault to
wouldn't have been a little bit
different because he kind of had to do
his but I just learned so much I never
knew games like that would be in place
yeah and I do think that uh Mike Pence
tonight absolutely sucked I know that
Patrick can't say that because again he
gets all the people actually they'll go
on on his show and rightfully so let me
speak for him like Vivek and uh just did
he went to ask him I have another
question for you so outside of Kerry
Lake and anybody that was on that debate
stage tonight do you see another Clear
Choice for vice president
uh I'm a fan of uh Christine gnome I'm a
fan of uh again look you you for a again
think about the alphaest person you know
in your life that operates and leads a
company or runs a team okay whoever that
Alpha is number two cannot be an alpha
your ambition cannot be to outshine the
alpha it's just not gonna work with it's
not going to work with a personality so
you got to take the person with a lot of
Ambitions of one day I would like to be
Etc so so that's not going to work out
when I be back because Vivek is very
ambitious I agree and he is very
confident and he is very driven and he
is very hard working and he believes in
himself and he knows how to sell the
dream he knows how to sell the nightmare
he knows how to relate to you he knows
how to rally and fire the audience up
every time he got up and spoke to people
were just energized when this guy speaks
and Americans want someone like that
right now because it's been a little bit
of a fear nightmare tomb and Gloom type
of America we've been living in for the
last three four years with way too much
animosity and tension and you know all
of this so I don't know I I don't see
that part but I think there's gonna be
keep this in mind with President Trump
he is a very unpredictable yet
predictable leader okay predictable in
the areas that is very predictably
values loyalty okay right he is
predictable in the area of wanting
someone that is you know not going to
want to outshine them but he's
unpredictable that he's going to
probably end up picking somebody no one
is thinking about just like he picked
Pence that's also very likely of
happening Stormy Daniels yes well he's
playing pickleball with her right now so
look I know that you are busy sir hey I
mean not that you need it but where's
the best place for people to to find you
support you because I always tell them
look if you're going to pick the top
three people out there doing programs
right now Patrick Bet David is one of
them where's the best place for people
to find you uh Patrick yeah you just you
just type Patrick if you can find us on
all socials Patrick David we have a
podcast called pbd podcast that uh we
cover a bunch of different things from
politics and business you can find us
everywhere see that was a very very
friendly way of him saying look let me
put her to it this way Google me
that's what he just said to me and I
look like an idiot Patrick David thank
you for taking time brother my man thank
you thank you take care guys thanks be
well Nick was laughing because you never
heard you never heard him before and I
guess it was probably the impression
once you guys no it's spot-on great
great guy but then he's awesome I'm
really asking because he said Peabody
pbd Patrick Davis
That's all folks yeah That's all folks
okay I was just thinking though how fast
was trying to call the vet out for his
inexperience look I could have said well
how did you know the thing is it didn't
hurt Trump let me put it to you that way
okay Mike Pence all right as a very
small penis right that's right okay uh
but Vivek right is an alpha so the two
go together One's Gonna Be a power One's
Gonna Be a power bottom all right and
One's Gonna Be a top and uh that's what
are you looking at Gerald you look crazy
looking at someone I don't know what
language something was just on my screen
Rumble had three of the top four streams
in the world tonight right we were the
top stream other than the actual just
clean GOP debate stream right so right A
lot of people for that that's Justin
Rumble not including YouTube members
yeah all the other mods that we we go
off of so you were a part of yeah
obviously something very big other than
um
yeah other than the original stream like
we were the largest thing out there
there was but there was something that
looked like it was probably a cricket
review I don't know are you saying
Ruffles of this show on this show on the
four largest shows at the time right
were Rumble shows
three of the four and we're number two
massive so thank you guys so much and
again please uh do consider and here's
one thing I know that we mentioned it
quite a few times tonight because of
that promo code Crowder GOP debate it
was number two it's ten dollars off but
hey would you rather us sell bowl and
Branch bed sheets and quip toothbrushes
that then start to turn into a vibrating
with a rainbow
oh I'm just saying you see those all
over the pot no hey patient control
bring that up bring that up quick
toothbrush to the rainbow toothbrush
baby that looked like a rainbow vibrator
that every single conservative was
selling that
don't you judge me okay Mr Nasty show
and you and your stupid boy scout FCC
[Laughter]
look no no the other one this one yeah
that one no no that's much the picture
is the latest picture in honor go there
bring up the quick toothbrush
we mentioned one thing tonight there's
been one in its Mud Club and that's
because of viewers like you have made
this the number two stream and by the
way that doesn't include all of the
other numbers out there so because of
you we're able to send investigative
Journal journalists out there because of
you we're able to bring the OG like Nick
de Paul on because if you were launching
shows like Brian Callan and like the
Hodge wins and we'll begin and Alex
Jones of course I predicted to the
Future by the way yeah by the way right
now he's doing he's doing the show at uh
on Friday but he wants to do the show
every single day and we have animated
shows documentaries that's that's
entirely because of viewers like you so
would you rather us plug a bowling
branch and quip and Birch gold and I'm G
Garden lady or you know well I guess no
they still run Gordon Liddy commercials
there's gold in them their ads yeah wow
that's too bad yeah oh so quiet I want
to hear what Mike Axelrod has to say in
a minute we'll have uh Jordan Peterson I
believe will be available to come on and
be good here God what he has to say he
was standing there but Patrick was going
along so he got pulled away but he's
going to come back and just you think
Jordan Peterson said listen Patrick I
appreciate but uh could you shut the
hell up for a moment just one moment
please listen my man Jordan Peterson
look you're a doctor okay but here's the
problem I'm the guy shut the hell up
no by the way isn't it great hey I don't
know if we'll get the candidates because
a lot of them are you know a lot of them
are are urinating their little panties
not not Nikki Haley of course because I
would never rehearse yeah everyone other
than her but uh restroom do we want to
do a quick commercial break as we get
Jordan Peterson on the line or figure
that out it'll be a few minutes for
Jordan Peterson but we can do a quick
break because these guys are just
basically just you know gas bags on CNN
and yeah so a quick break everyone here
has to urinate really quickly we'll come
back Jordan Peterson most likely and
then we'll see which other candidates
are available and then of course we will
take your chats go exclusive to mug Club
Nick depalo Gerald Morgan enjoy this
quick commercial break while I relieve
myself
okay
[Music]
some people have a deep abiding respect
for the Constitutional law that created
this country
and some people don't
it started liberalism
mug clock can stop it
and now for the adventures of the white
privilege boy
[Music]
all right there now Timmy I know you're
a teenager but if I've told you once
I've told you a thousand times you can't
park your vehicle faced into oncoming
traffic come on let's move well gee
officer I'm sure sorry can I just go
back to my car no no I want you to
follow my instructions either get down
on the ground or follow me away from the
vehicle but officer can I just get my
PCP nah well you know usually I'd say no
but you can make it quick come on get on
out of here you White Rascal oh boy I'm
in a free base
when they find themselves in next stay
tuned for next week's installment of
Adventures of the white privilege boys
got today you're not setting your best
everybody said you right back look at
over there well let's keep building this
wall there you go Brick by Brick by wall
frankly shoots fire you see and you're
gonna pay for it
history
hey guys uh in the chat let me know what
you'd like me to put in my boat
I'm thinking alligators and spikes
[Music]
Gerald that is by far got it that is by
far one of my others there's people
running behind me oh my gosh that's one
of my favorite sketches that we've ever
done was Trump playing Minecraft
building the wall oh my God it was
fantastic
um so look I I know we've got people
that we're working on right now if you
see on like CNN Fox everybody right now
there's a spin room right so the spin
room is basically where they go to do
interviews and to talk about what just
happened essentially what we're doing
here what CNN sucks at doing and what
obviously uh many many more of you are
watching us do this they actually had a
bit of an issue and I don't know how it
got resolved but apparently Matt Gates
representative Matt Gates out of Florida
said that it was resolved they were not
letting any of the Trump surrogates
basically people who are going to go in
and kind of represent Donald Trump like
Kerry lake or anybody that may have been
a miscommunication though I think it was
intentionally miscommunicated if it was
I think this is Fox being petty because
Fox is a little pissed off at Tucker and
they're they're pissed off at Trump
right and they are basically saying hey
you know we're going to make this a
little bit more difficult for you Donald
Trump Jr you're not welcome Kimberly
Guilford you're not welcome right things
like that are happening I think they did
finally get it sorted out maybe they
were making a big deal out of it maybe
maybe that was the whole story to this
but I think what we're seeing right now
bigger I don't know how to say this the
right way bigger than the debate that we
just saw we're witnessing the death of
mainstream media which also tells you
how out of touch these candidates are
that they're appearing with Dana Nash on
CNN right everyone every single time
it's like Vivek get out of the room
nobody's going to be watching these
people yeah right so with Rumble being
the sponsor in streaming like you're
seeing very very large numbers of people
watching this online you're off of
YouTube by the way off of YouTube off of
Facebook YouTube and Facebook the
biggest players out there you're seeing
people kind of run out of this and go
you know what you're seeing a moment in
time where these people are going to
look back and go this is the death nail
right no longer do we control the
politics that people want to see no
longer do we control the questions that
get asked because think about this if
you're somebody who's Brett Bear or
Martha McCallum you have to be careful
sometimes the questions you ask because
maybe they aren't going to come on your
show next week maybe they're not going
to be exactly at the at the network that
you're going to get called what was it
the second floor if you ever got called
to the second floor you knew that Fox
News it was a second floor yeah problem
right yeah that's right all the
executives we don't care we're not going
to be jerks just to be jerks like the
Click bait stuff that people do you
never want to sandbag anyone but we want
to ask the questions that people have
exactly yeah the normal everyday
American that has a question like look I
get it I was talking with Marjorie
Taylor green and congresswoman she's she
was much nicer I've never really met her
I just thought she was a little bit
fiery in most of the things that I saw
very nice she said look it's a 10-year
problem to fix you've got to give us the
house and the senate in the white house
I'm like look we've done that maybe we
didn't do it for 10 years but we gave
you that and we've been burned so many
times
can you promise me that it's gonna
happen this time because I don't want to
be left at the altar yet how many times
have we had and I you know Ted Cruz
Marco Rubio Dan Crenshaw on no and talk
about section you know 230 230. and then
nothing is actually done I said remember
we had I don't know if you guys have
noticed this but I don't have anything
against the guy Dan Crenshaw last time
he was on he supported the Taps act
everyone else gave him a softball and I
said how is that not red flag laws and I
asked him okay let me ask you a
different way how are you going to
guarantee that the tap sack that you're
supporting does not turn into red flag
type laws where a neighbor can simply in
a disgruntled state report a neighbor
who they don't like and they forfeit
their second amendment rights he didn't
have an answer not saying that Dan
Crenshaw is a bad guy but we asked that
question in real time where he was
immensely popular now a lot of people
have those issues with with
representative Crenshaw now but at the
time it was a question that was
important and no one else was willing to
ask we have had these questions for
people we never by the way we never aim
to be disrespectful no well of course
this is honestly people are often
surprised when they sit down we go look
we match your intensity but we're also
not going to do the bidding of the donor
class right that is a big difference
between what we do if we we're doing the
bidding of the donor class you think
Nick depalo would be here who by the way
told me he didn't have to go to the
bathroom he said no I'm doing all right
and then I come back he's gone for nine
minutes yeah because I hope he had a
hell of a piss Arnold yeah well I gotta
prostate the size of you know the statue
in Liberty the size of Chris Christie
exactly no but that's right so when when
we had uh Senator Rubio on we we
basically was asked him and said yeah we
pressed him and said look if you don't
fix 230 you may not be around yeah
because maybe they can just lock you out
you won't have a voice this is the kind
of thing that needs to get fixed ASAP
and look I I love and you can go online
we'll probably put it up for Mud Club
the full interviews that we did I know
we showed some segments of it today yeah
but you can see that full interview and
I was just like look 10 years
please uh sound off in the uh the chat
there that Gerald you know Gerald is uh
he's now migrated to this full-time I
mean you worked here part-time for I
guess going back to 2015 in some
capacity
um yeah you know what happened here's
the story yeah here's a story about
Jerry that doesn't happen to me oh boy
Gerald do you remember the conversation
so Gerald said when we were we were in
these contract disputes and I said you
know I I just I really want to be
independent and kind of Break Free of
these shackles this is this was a really
Earnest moment and Gerald said I think
he can do it and I think that uh if you
do it this way he kind of went through
potentially you know as far as sign ups
and as far as our merch shop which you
can go to crowdershop.com he said you
can do it and I said I know
but if I do it independently
I need and you said you're going to need
someone to handle it yeah not going to
be able to handle that all yourself and
he was that guy so he said all right let
me step in yep and God in the in the
form of Gerald Morgan who by the way
have a tight end yes yes well to this
day can I ask you guys a question
because I know you were discussing 2 30.
can you refresh my memory I know it has
something to do with it so platforms
being immune to Yeah so basically okay
when you for example uh like Sprint or
Verizon or in your case Metro PCS
manipulated as a public utility right
meaning that even if you're a Neo-Nazi
and you're not committing a crime they
can't shut you down right that's a
different regulation right they're
afforded certain Liberties in other
words they're not liable for what people
are saying across their their their uh
their uh cell towers same thing applies
by the way to like for example the Town
Square so 230 has extended to the
digital Town Square meaning that places
like Twitter Facebook YouTube they're
not seen as Publishers like the New York
times.com right they're seen as digital
Town squares which means they do not
editorialize they do not censor content
based on point of view which of course
them right but they benefit from in
other words you can't sue you can't
right so we have it both ways they're
having it both ways and so all I'm
saying is the way that you solve it is
say you are either a platform or you are
a publisher and considering that YouTube
has removed our content and suspended us
four points of view and preemptively
said send us your content so that we can
tell you if it's acceptable or not I
wouldn't by the way what we did it and
they wouldn't right vaccine thing we
were like hey can you tell us if this is
the vaccine parity yeah it shouldn't but
we just want to make sure there's like
who's already the movement to stop
it gives them the protection but they're
abusing it yes and we're trying who just
reverse change that well they all say
that they are no he's too busy hitting
an ankle pick on uh what they're not
trying hard enough yeah they're not
doing enough in other words
the problem too if you're a conservative
Media company and you're making quite
literally tens of millions of dollars
off of YouTube the easiest path to make
money right now by the way you guys need
understand this is make money off of
YouTube advertising Google AdSense and
Facebook Instant articles that's the
easiest way you could literally have
never created an original piece of
content just copy paste hat tip and make
tens of millions of dollars and many
people out there do
that's that's a that's a constant it's
something that we have been up against
for a very long time and that does not
encourage conservatives and Republicans
to do better and that's why they feel
comfortable right now for crying out
loud right now bergam is appearing with
Dana Bash on CNN could you be any more
toned any more predictable they've had
Mike Pence on who they have they just
had they just had a vivicon but the fact
that they're doing this like what do you
think man I really have to I really have
to bring my message to the people let me
go talk with Dana Bash they're just used
to it it's well they have to get out of
the old nobody's interviewed anybody
from Transylvania on CNN that's true let
me tell you something well you know what
I tell you what he certainly did stand
up to those Ottomans so
it worked out no I think people do get
stuck in these old patterns where
they're like oh I have to give a canned
answer oh I have to I have to be a
little bit more kind of upright in these
debates and and not show the personality
and the fire that really got me here in
the first place and now I have to go
talk to CNN and MSNBC and fox and CBS I
gotta talk to all these guys no no what
you need to do is bypass The Gatekeepers
you start taking power away from them
look the two there are two things in
this industry I'm going to give you some
inside baseball here that are hardest to
cheat and I've said this for a very long
you can buy views on platforms okay
especially if you have billions of
dollars or hundreds of millions of
non-profit uh funding the hardest
numbers to cheat are live viewership and
ticket sales that's why when people
point to Donald Trump's rallies I get it
you can have a big rally and maybe not
win a general election that is plausible
though not likely right but it is very
very hard to cheat consistently having
people come out to your rallies or pay a
ticket to go see you speak in person or
people at that in other words tonight
when these streams are going on you have
the choice to tune in anywhere we cannot
pay to plump up our viewership because
it has to go through a 24-hour approval
process whoever tuned in you tuned in
those are the two toughest numbers to
cheat and so I will tell you this if
nothing else if you want to know if
you're having the world pulled over your
eyes if you see a huge Media Company
online that has these these huge plays
right millions of plays and Tim you know
you run up against us everybody runs
social here on YouTube on Facebook you
go it has five million plays but they're
consistently getting a few thousand or
maybe even 15 000 on a good day twenty
thousand live viewers that means there's
a disconnect and that's why you know
what a good example by the way Patrick
but David has great live viewership uh
Jordan Peterson sells more tickets out
there than anyone in the conservative
movement I was thinking about this in
the drive over today and I would love to
hear from you who would you say are the
top three shows online like the top
three podcasters out there doing I would
say Patrick Bet David is up there for
sure uh Jordan Peterson in his field
he's he's Untouchable and Mark Maron and
yeah yeah well I guess in The Count of
Monte Cristo look-alike invention
um
I was I wasn't gonna say it because I
didn't know if you were friends with him
or not I I don't have a problem I mean
oh okay I do a lot of people so no no no
I just you know hey guys I got a scare
me so yeah I know this is going to be
interesting so they're fact checking the
debate right now they brought on the on
Syrian glasses on CNN oh here we go
number three I would say Joe Rogan
because the first movers rights he
stayed in when everybody else pulled out
and uh so I would say Patrick Bet David
Jordan Peterson
Joe we're all going to be in my top
three I'd love to hear yours let's see
the fact check from this uh Rayne Wilson
look like green open is misleading at
best and that's because Governor
DeSantis is omitting a bunch of
information look it's two queers one cup
what he did early in the pandemic here
is the reality certainly between two
points
thought bubbles over the head right now
on foreign
for the rest of the school year do you
know what that means for a couple of
months yeah because it was in early
April late March that we were talking
about this the closing of all of this
stuff and he's like he closed it for the
rest of the school year he's not telling
the truth because he did close things
down for Florida he opened them sooner
than most people did yes the context
matters if you had your way and by that
I mean known Democrat shells yes
Anderson Cooper and this man His Name
Escapes me because I don't like to
remember it you are included but here's
the thing if what kind of policies would
you have if left unfettered kids still
wouldn't be in school of course that's
without a hint of hyperbole like Chicago
children would not be back in school and
if so at the very least with masks on
which the which by the way the
literature someone can bring us up for
Mission Control show and I know it's not
a perfect clinical trial because you're
not going to have that with masks
because you can't have a placebo control
group just to be clear it's We're not
gonna have a golden standard but if you
look at the meta-analyzes children who
wore a mask infrequently or not at all
were less likely to have severe coveted
complications than children who wore a
mask that's not what Randy Weingarten
said I thought you were saying Randy
Newman yeah the same thing you know I'm
going to wear a mask not going because
math schools after the test
I can't breathe because I'm wearing this
mask
give me another Grammy man
that guy sucks oh Randy do you like him
very talented well yeah I don't like him
but I know he's talented that was their
big fact check by the way they've gone
to commercial the fact check was Ron
DeSantis wasn't telling you the whole
story about the lockdowns he needs to be
and he was like very adamant about that
and I was I was kind of trying to read
his lips that's all they do no they're
trying to point out these small things
where it's like of course everybody
closed down everybody was worried
initially about this right but it's what
he did once we go ah absolutely
right now he's wondering we're not at
home is anybody taking him out
he does that by the way clears the room
I don't know what they're doing uh South
India I don't want him to eat at me no
no I love that all right good boy by the
way let's break up a tweet from our uh
former vice president uh Joseph R for
Robinette he's going back to Nick um by
the way that's because Nick feeds him
from the table he does I do not feed him
you and Alex
son's a he took my phone by the
way it's sons of if you could I
am from Canada
he says I've been playing for the
Canadian for two three years you got me
cussing over here I apologize yeah blame
it on me you Hellion yeah so this is
from uh Joseph by the way took my food
a bunch of Republicans on stage one
United Mega ideology from our on-air
Channel
that's not it at all I mean
I mean Joseph R Biden the hell was that
oh that's Trump looking at it from
himself that's the what she said to me
the one right above that yes we're doing
this live without a net well and he's
he's because she's better what we've
been drinking the Tweet right above that
I mean it's literally half an inch above
that that's what she's good bring it up
bring it up do it yeah a bunch of
Republicans on stage one United Mega
ideology oh what's this Hollywood
Squares yeah exactly
yeah he's the middle Square on the age
quilt this is Joe Biden trying to wait
was that supposed to be clever that's
what I mean
Kenny Rogers if I can genius
wait Kenny Rogers Kenny Rogers yeah yeah
the singer came up with that one all
right no Kenny Rogers oh you just hit my
shoes it's a good year welt
cheese
what's that made of shark's teeth I
don't know but I tell you what I do know
when he said that stupid white dog that
felt bad for Nick coming out of his
mouth because he loves Joe Lewis
if I could have a dog on the planet I
would kidnap that thing I traded the way
it deserves to be not the way you treat
it
[Laughter]
he is this he likes it sweetest scariest
dog I've ever seen he's the scariest
looking dog I've never seen him dislike
anybody he doesn't mean well me I hate
everybody oh yeah he just likes Stray
Cats let's grab a couple of uh of chats
because we're waiting on obviously Dr uh
Peterson we'll see if he gets in there
yeah uh and outside then we can go you
know what we can go to mug club and if
these candidates want to want to wait
then it'll just be on mug Club we'll run
it on uh as a clip tomorrow but let's
grab a few chats and thank you again the
promo code is a Crowder GOP debate uh
ten dollars off and he will be at Rob's
comedy Playhouse September 15th
somewhere in New York Buffalo Buffalo
here I am in front of my people remember
any everything here I am in front of my
pizza place I love that picture
all right so here's a here's a question
for Steven what were your thoughts on
the questions and what issues do you
think needed to be addressed during the
debate well I was just very surprised
that they started off so quickly with
the climate change is the number one
issue and how they partnered with young
America's Foundation that seemed odd to
me yeah um maybe it's just me and then
right away going into the abortion in a
way that was hedged really as though it
was written from salon.com or slate uh I
think that we learned today look and I
and I've always tried to be really
careful about this you know this Gerald
because I was at Fox News for four and a
half years right uh they never liked me
uh to be clear well actually that's not
true two people did and then Roger Ailes
did not uh he also like banned Norm
Macdonald for life so I felt like okay
I'm doing all right in other words they
don't just hate everybody but yeah uh I
was there for four and a half years so
I've tried to be objective
they're not your friends they're not
your allies Fox News I think we learned
that tonight would you say so Gerald it
did not seem like they were being
even-handed I think that's reasonable I
mean you've got an entire field of
Republicans and so you have to ask
questions to kind of push them a little
bit and get the conversation going but
when you talk about climate change as a
settled thing that's a debate right now
with the conservatives and what part we
plan and what we should do literally
spending trillions of dollars and
shutting down world economies to to try
to make sure that we go green instead of
letting Africa I don't know use coal by
the way every single freaking electric
vehicle out there is powered by coal so
thank you we just had an ad for the
Cadillac the new uh EV from Cadillac
like 450 mile range which by the way you
know is probably 30 better than it
actually gets that's one tank of gas
seriously and the gas mileage in my SUV
is offensive
it definitely is but I I also think that
they are not pushing back the way that
they used to no Fox News yeah Fox used
to be they can't the rebels and look
again they're never going to be that
again they're never going can I say
rumble those guys are the rebels yeah
they're the ones out there what is it
what it what did uh your your Mentor say
Andrew punk rock yeah like that's what
they are so Rumble lean into that don't
try to be friends with these people go
in there and burn the damn thing down
and put a nail in the coffin for us all
so that we can just move on and that's
what I love about Rubble they're not
trying to burn anything down but they
are what they are and uh I couldn't be
happier to be partnered you know why
they don't have a woman as a CEO start
there that's serious Chris is what
you're about to say that before that
that was it oh was it okay Suzanne Scott
and whoever the hell else yeah what are
the kids yeah
Murdoch and yeah those two yeah they go
to freaking Berkeley yeah yeah
I always have to be careful because the
manager Tommy's being interviewed
vivek's brother I like gay video by the
way we do have Jordan Peterson on the
way it's on the way just a minute he'll
be seeing a notebook let's grab another
uh another chat all right we got another
chat here it's a question for crew how
bad would Trump bulldoze Republican
nominees's if he had been at the debate
um but we talked about that again I
think you have to imagine okay Donald
Trump there next to put him next to
Christy put him next to Tim Scott put
him next to Vivek put him next to Ron
DeSantis put him next to Nikki Haley
um I think everyone comes out of there
like I said earlier on uh tonight
everyone comes out of that debate
tonight worse off than they went in with
the exception of Vivek uh and I I don't
know I guess sort of yeah DeSantis I
it's there's still a question mark I
don't think that the scientist answered
the questions that he needed to tonight
that's what I think is probably and I'm
not a political junkie so I know other
people have yeah but but we the way we
were doing this tonight we'd turn it
down while they were answering stuff we
didn't a little bit right yeah we missed
some of it yeah we must have just say it
no there were a lot of fat jokes why is
Johnny
[Laughter]
about 45 years
um let's test this Zoomer I think yeah
yeah well that's because Chris Christie
hasn't seen his Dick Cavett all right
let's uh we have Jordan Evan oh we have
doctor uh do we have him yeah go for it
all right so right now of course we had
Patrick Bet David like I said if I were
going to put my top three uh people out
there kind of fighting the good fight in
their shows their podcast uh Patrick
that David would be there and uh Dr
Jordan Peterson yeah boy I believe we
have on right now um doc can you see me
can you hear me sir
Hey Stephen how are you doing man I am
doing well hold on a second I'm trying
to that is is that like a is that a
jacket that's almost like a toothpaste
it's from Don Cherry white Ensemble it's
Don Cherry exactly well I am a Canadian
you know yes it's necessary to have a
suit like this and that's that's because
in Rumble you can't go out of bounds so
uh Dr Peterson
um what did you think what was your take
and by the way the best I think you can
just Google Jordan Peterson and find
everything that he does uh if I'm
missing the most effective plug he's so
ubiquitous doc what was your takeaway
tonight on on this debate
well the first thing I thought was that
I thought all the candidates did did a
credible job I thought it was actually a
pretty strong playing field I thought
each of them hit some points home
effectively
um
and then you know I had I have opinions
about each of the different candidates
performances
um I thought Vivek ramaswamy
evoked the most positive and the most
negative response from the audience you
know he's very charismatic and so he can
he can he can he can produce that
extremely broad response from the
audience
so the challenge for Vivek will be to
learn how to minimize that the negative
consequences of his somewhat impulsive
style and to capitalize more on the
attractiveness of his vision I think
because I think when he does that he's
very strong I think his use of insult in
relationship to the other candidates was
not didn't do him any particular good I
don't think it hit well I think it
turned them against him in a way that
was somewhat counterproductive for him
but I also don't think that it sat well
with the audience I thought DeSantis you
know I'd give DeSantis a pretty solid
b-plus performance rating with very
little variability he was stable and
credible the whole time I thought that
Mike Pence was quite statesmanlike that
Chris Christie showed a fair bit of
spine I like the North Dakota governor
he looks like a credible guy it doesn't
look to me like he's in the race to the
same degree as the rest of the
candidates I thought Nikki Haley scored
the odd point desantos was very strong
on the southern Border Protection issue
so
um Tim Scott has a good sense of humor
although I thought that he was he's he
played
polite
I think he is polite and I think he is a
genuinely good person but there was a
kind of uh there's a there's a harshness
that might also be introduced into the
realm that I don't think that he
capitalized on
so he needed a little more Tim Scott he
needed to get in there go after the puck
a little more yeah and I don't think he
did
yeah yeah well and you know by the same
token he didn't make any mistakes that
made it look like he was unfit for the
job and I actually think that was the
case for all of the candidates so
I think as is showing on the Republican
side it was quite strong
um it's a tricky debate Forum with that
many people talking because it's very
difficult to develop any ideas in any
detail so you know that was challenging
I think it was unfortunate that Trump
wasn't there I think it's not good that
both Biden and Trump have decided that
they're not going to participate in
these debates because the debates are
crucial and I think participating them
is a show of strength and a show of
respect I mean Trump made a brilliant
move tonight going to see Tucker Carlson
Instead at the same time let me say one
thing you're uh uh I slightly disagree
and let me explain sort of my premise
here I said this before the running of
these debates
um everyone's been talking about and I
agree with you that for Donald Trump
strategically right it was a risk he
didn't need to take but I also think
that everyone there tonight really
should be thanking their lucky stars
um the best thing that could have
happened to them from a selfish
perspective but as far as advancing is
Donald Trump not being there because
every time I'm watching these people
answer with the exception of Vivek
DeSantis certainly Pence certainly Nikki
Haley certainly Chris Christie and I'm
going let me put them right next to
Donald Trump every single one of them
tonight would have left that that debate
far more bruised and battered if Donald
Trump had been there so it's almost a
benevolent fair enough yeah I mean think
about we don't want to do damage to the
Republican party right you know
hey look it might have been advantageous
to these candidates for that to be the
case see the playing field was a lot
more level yeah
um so so I don't think that they can
necessarily complain about the fact that
he wasn't there I think it's unfortunate
on a broader level right
that he's foregone the debates but you
know it's early in the campaign and God
only knows what's going to happen I mean
the world's a very strange place at the
moment and no one has any idea what's
going to happen between now and November
right I mean you're absolutely let me
ask you this from a perspective of
someone who obviously has literally run
up against I guess figuratively but
quite literally gone up against the
Canadian government litter figuratively
run up against them literally actually
had to actively fight the Canadian
government the Free Speech issue is
obviously
um something that's pivotal to you there
was just a new uh I think it was a case
or a ruling there in Canada and I've
always said that the United States is
the greatest country in the world
because it's the only country where
freedom of speech exists in your gut
whereas someone and I know that free
speech is near and dear to your soul
watching that tonight who would you have
the most trust in as far as someone who
would be a defender of freedom of speech
because it's a pivotal issue it extends
to Big Tech and extends to media in
general and of course that affects all
of us did you have a gut feeling of this
might be someone who will be in our
corner
thank you
that's a tough one you know I I think I
guess I would pick I I this isn't
precise answer to your question but I
would have some faith in Pence
Christie
and Vivek okay probably so there's four
and dissentis you know no I think those
people would
would fight for that
um for different reasons
um I think Pence would fight for it
because it's a right I think Vivek would
fight for it because he knows you can't
think without free speech I think
DeSantis would fight for it
I think he would fight for it on
Principle as well yeah that would be
more constitutional argument
um Christy I think would fight for it
because Christie's Christie's go to
spine he's a tough character and and uh
I don't think he's the sort of person
that would allow anyone to interfere
with his Free Speech you know and so
I'm pretty confident you know you don't
know what Temptations will be set
someone when they obtain a substantive
amount of power right
um but
I certainly have a lot more faith on the
Republican side of the political
distribution in relationship between
protections for free speech than I do on
the Democrat side yeah I mean look we
know Biden we know you know I guess I
take it personally to some degree too
because I know absolutely perfectly well
because this was all revealed that Biden
told Facebook for example to
preferentially uh promote the New York
Times And The Wall Street Journal
directly over the daily wire and of
course I'm quite you know tightly
associated with them so I'm in that of
course in that camp of reprehensible
individuals yes so isn't it funny for
anyone to say look and I know of course
you're going to have liberals who who
hate Jordan Peterson but for anyone to
put the words reprehensible and Jordan
Peterson together those are silly people
you can't say that doc but I will I
think Gerald has a question yeah and I
know we have to wrap you in just a
couple of minutes here I know you've got
some other things to do but I just he's
a busy man yeah Dr Peterson I I agree
with you on Vivek I I started to see the
same thing the audience didn't react the
same way that I thought they would but
he was kind of a Marked Man going into
this debate like DeSantis needed to do
some damage on him but he's he he's
basically gobbling up all of his votes
so yeah is there another strategy he
could have taken like I think it was
kind of nice to see him go was it
necessary a little bit you mean what you
did a different strategy for Vivek or
for disaster for basically going on the
offensive and punching out well no I
think there were some things he could
have done and that that would have been
helpful I think that Pence was quite
markedly professional in his use of
pauses you know he controlled the pace
of the dialogue and Vivek is quite
impulsive and quick and I think that
that highlights his youthfulness in a
way that's not not useful to him I think
that more explanation and less criticism
would have worked better again and made
him look more sagacious and more mature
um
I think he could have done that that and
in a manner that would have only be
advantageous to him and I also think
that he could have highlighted his as I
said earlier his concern for the
disenfranchised working class
particularly on economic rounds and I
think that was a weakness in the entire
field they've left that field they've
left that part of the political domain
for Trump and that's not smart because
that's really where Trump is strongest
yeah I think you're right I think they
maybe uh vivec was smart to go into the
immigration issue because that does tie
in with the American working class who
that's a big reason that Trump surged in
2016 and I don't think that Fox News was
really doing a very good job of trying
to at least lay up the issues for them
where they would be strongest to answer
I mean going into climate change and
abortion I don't know I was a little
disappointed but I know that you have to
wrap up you have you're the bell of the
ball tonight doc where's the best place
for people to find you and support you
because you're everywhere these days
well I mean for people are certainly
more than welcome to take a look at my
books if they're inclined to do that um
they that place I'm most active is
really on YouTube that's the right place
to follow me that's where I mean apart
from the books obviously
um that's where I'm
I suppose at my best I don't know if I'm
on my best at my best in Twitter on
Twitter for example but no one is it's
entertaining and by the way necessary
necessary sneak pics you correct your
dirty mouth it's X doctor yes sex I'm
sorry and I will get that right
eventually yeah
none of us will all right so on YouTube
and of course your books everyone knows
I mean it's one of the best-selling
books that I can think of certainly in
in these I just say one thing yeah you
want his book and I want to thank
Dr Peterson for his book I was going
through some tough stuff yeah about six
seven years ago and I made a little bit
of a mess of my marriage in his book
basically the gist of it was you got to
do the right thing yeah and it it really
one of the few books has ever had an
impact on me so I I wanted to thank
thank you so much for that and I live in
Savannah Georgia I think you opened a
center down there or something or you're
going to yeah yeah right yeah yeah well
there's a yeah there's a new University
down there Ralston Ralston Ralston
College on bricks and mortar institution
and I'm starting this Peterson Academy
which my daughter is running and we're
going to cut the cost of a of a
university equivalent degree down to
something approximating four thousand
dollars which I think would be
absolutely comical and I think we can do
it too so well Dr Peterson thank you
radical proposal we run in different
circles but uh you know Nick just in
case you didn't know Nick depalo is the
OG in comedy he's probably one of the
most respected joke writers and known as
one of the meanest comics in the
business so if anyone were to tell you
or tell anyone 12 years ago that Nick
depala will be thanking Jordan Peterson
for a book that tells him how to improve
his character and moral fiber they would
have they would have called you an
absolutely insane person so that shows
the kind of people that you're able to
reach and take some time Nick depala one
of the funniest men but an animal a
Savage Dr Peterson I know you're busy
sir thanks for taking the time brother
thank you hey man it's really good to
talk to you and I'm very happy to hear
that my book was helpful I'm I'm always
very happy to hear that that was the
whole point of writing the damn thing
thank you sir well I really appreciate
he really really needs it thank you Mr
thank you Dr Peterson appreciate it all
right so that is insanity yeah
absolutely
not make your bed you see oh you look at
me see a dumb Italian I didn't say dumb
Italian you don't have to the black guys
are right a lot about a lot of this
stuff okay I could pigeon like I'm
serious I get pigeonholed and uh I read
I get plenty of books at home whether
it's Jordan Peterson whether it was back
to Dave Newt Gingrich Pat Buchanan uh
even uh I was gonna say Chomsky but that
would be a lie yeah but I'm just saying
uh I just don't have I'm not a
pretentious who has to show it
like a lot of them no I just never know
the Allure like but you know what Nick
de Paulo is actually he's a he's a kind
man I mean I saw five minutes of him on
YouTube one night and went oh my God
yeah this guy is absolutely brilliant we
uh we were really covering him uh with
Bill uh c16 there in Canada before he
you know had appeared on Rogan and
before he had sort of broken I said look
this is a guy who's really fighting the
fight against the Canadian government as
a professor and I couldn't be more happy
that he's done uh as well as he has and
I just he's just one of those guys he
just needs to get out in front of people
when if you have heard the left describe
Jordan Peterson you'll think he's a
monster if you've heard Jordan Peterson
in his own words to know him as to love
him so uh was Rush Limbaugh yeah that's
all I heard was how evil he was and I
put it on and I'm like I haven't heard
him say like even close to a dark thing
right now that's what the same thing
that I had heard about you and I tuned
in and I said well I see the point yeah
well I but it's okay we need all
different kinds of Warriors no you're
right I do it for you know you don't
think Dr peace would love to let it fly
like I do some nights well I know he's a
big fan of trailer park boys which means
he does have a little bit of a dark side
to him and again the promo code is
Crowder GOP debate 10 off at ladder with
credit.com
um and we're about to go do we have uh
we're gonna have Don Jr here in just a
second oh great should we go to the Mud
Club or uh I mean at some point I mean
we've been going for three and a half
hours yeah yeah let's let's probably go
to yeah all right so look we're gonna
have Donald Trump Jr uh some clips of
that and we'll have some more Clips with
Donald Trump Jr tomorrow if you can't be
but look if you're a freeloader I
understand seven dollars a month is is
genuinely I'm not just saying this I get
as tough for some people but what you
get you get twice the show later with
Crowder you get Nick depalo uh four
times a week you get Alex Jones and his
full-length show deep Dives on Friday
gonna get Brian Callan Hodge twins uh Mr
you know get Mr guns and gear uh we're
adding some new series uh every single
yeah week and more importantly none of
this exists period without the support
of you please do hit the like button uh
if you're on YouTube subscribe head on
the best thing you can do is subscribe
to rumble if you're on Rumble right now
tell them right there you just click
that button right there boom you join Up
Mud Club you go through that portal and
you can see what's live at any given
moment in any given day we really
appreciate you thank you so much this
has been Crowder GOP debate Nick depalo
at so and so comedy Playhouse in Buffalo
let's just get a number and uh
Rumble thank you YouTube piss off
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
Donald Trump Jr can you hear me sir I I
can hear you fantastic how was it being
there I was there yesterday I had to
leave to get back here for the debate I
had to catch an ungodly early flight out
of here but I wish that I was there to
sit in the room what was your take on
what was going on in the debate
uh it was amazing I mean Trump won a
debate without even having to be
president
I'm sorry Don Junior I took I did a half
P because I out of respect for you I I
cinched it up and now it burns and then
I hear everyone laughing so I'm sorry I
don't know what I missed what happened
literally they they asked me how I
thought it went tonight I said it was
incredible I mean there's nothing like
winning a debate without having to even
show up yeah no hold on they didn't ask
you it was me John it was me look he
doesn't I can't see the screen it's okay
are we on live now or are we just
talking no we are we are always live so
you know careful with our comments about
well listen I saw DiPaolo on the screen
there and I just wanted to thank Nick
because I think a he's hilarious but
more importantly he paid me one of the
great compliments I've ever received
actually I was speaking somewhere I
think it was in Georgia one time
Savannah showed up in